super coven
what's here everybody the mutants
strained they're literally calling it
super covet it's in california
it's in colorado and due to the
overwhelming surge
sweeping through the hospitals in
california they're announcing the
lockdown is now
indefinite it's not just a lockdown it's
a stay at home order
people have already started losing it a
group of about 50 maskless people
stormed into a store furious
and so it seems like code is not going
anywhere
you know i know trump said one day it'll
go away a lot of republicans were
speculating oh as soon as
you know joe biden wins then they're
going to claim it's gone why would they
i mean first of all there's actually a
virus called covid
and you know people get sick and they
die from it but more importantly
the emergencies empower those you know
it gives power to the authorities
declaring an emergency is the easiest
way to oppress suppress
and and stay in power so even if it was
this like
even if you know many people were saying
that it was going to go away even if
that were true
that's that's kind of ridiculous because
people don't want to give up power i
think the reality is though
there's a there you know there's a very
serious virus we got to take it
seriously
but whether or not it makes sense to
shut
everything down have the economy be
totally destroyed and cause this mass
suffering
i don't believe that actually makes
sense we we're trying to slow the spread
we did it as best as we could but
now more and more people are getting
sick and it's because we've always known
they told us
the world health organization various
organizations said we can't stop people
from getting sick we can only slow the
spread
yet now here we are california saying
indefinite lockdown
this was we were told by by the world
health organization this could be
avoided
apparently it can't be or apparently
people just you know it's convenient for
people like newsome to say you know you
guys stay home so i got to deal with and
then i'll go out and party
and that's the problem if there really
was a very serious issue
uh assuming they're you know look
there's a pandemic it's a very serious
issue
the the problem we have is our leaders
like
i say our leaders but you know certain
individuals in office like cuomo
and like whitmer like newsom they
violate covet lockdown so why should
anyone
take them seriously why is it that these
elites these political elites are not
scared at all
break their own rules even dr burks
herself
from the covet task force breaking the
rules so we're gonna talk a lot about
this and we've got uh probably one of
the best people to talk to about it
peak uh peak prosperity you wanna you
wanna introduce yourself
more formally i suppose uh sure i'm
chris martinson dr chris martin i got a
phd in pathology
and i've been covering kovid non-stop
since i first figured it out january
23rd was my first
video launch of that and um i've been uh
just diving into the science behind it a
lot now peak prosperity is your youtube
channel
it is and it's also my website and and
there we normally talk about where we're
going in the
economy we you know for years for a
decade i've been talking about the
federal reserve i've been talking about
uh
monetary printing i've been talking
about oil resources all kinds of stuff
right
but then kovit comes along i'm like oh
you know it's going to be a bit of a
game changer so i dusted off the old
science credentials and
dove in and it what a journey it's been
i'm not at all where i started in this
story
it's interesting too uh just before
before the show a couple couple times
you're mentioning that we are running
out of resources so there's there's
serious consideration for
what happens to us if we do does that
imply that there's a net that at least
some kind of benefit to
a lockdown you could look at it that way
and and i
i see this pattern happening right so
climate change comes along and
and the story behind climate change is
hey there's this existential threat and
it's so bad that what we really need to
do
is stop consuming you know we have to
stop burning carbon you hear these crazy
plans like oh we'll decarbonize 50
by 2030 right if you did that the next
question you should ask those people who
say that is
which half of the people are going to
die in which 70 percent of the jobs are
going to go away that's the question i
had for greta tunberg
not literally i mean she's just a kid
she doesn't understand when
when she said we want to stop the you
know the oil uh
next year she's like we don't wait till
20 50 20 30. we mean next year 2021 or
whatever
i'm like well i think the actual
calculations from like the world health
organization is millions would die
instantly so we're gonna talk about all
this chris great to have you luke's also
hanging out
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name is lukadowski of the
youtube channel we are
change i am super excited about the
conversation today i think it's going to
be a very
important one and tim it's not just
california going under a full lockdown
it's also the united kingdom
that is now expanding its lockdown and
according to some government sources
there are warning that there is a high
chance of a
full national lockdown in the new year
so
that's also breaking news happening
right now that i just saw in the united
kingdom bro this reminds me of kingsman
i mentioned this before but you ever see
that movie kingsman the bad guy
samuel jackson's like climate change is
destroying the planet so we need all the
people to go and like fight each other
to the death so that the planet survives
like when you say that we're running out
of resources then you have these massive
lockdowns i'm like dude
they're already warning us that in the
uk there's going to be food shortages
it's going to get crazy all right well
we'll save it we'll see we'll talk about
stuff ian he's chilling he's got he's
got a special
spinning object me and my gorilla and uh
this primal youth that tim got me for
christmas
uh dr jones primal youth give it a spin
so we actually are getting some shirts
made that says i am a gorilla
because people keep posting guerrilla
emojis like non-stop in the chat
and they keep saying i am a gorilla and
so i guess uh
gorilla is the show mascot for some
reason at least for now i guess it
sounds like you said gorilla-ism
gorilla-ism gorilla
yeah uh lydia is also producing she's
pushing all those pushing buttons over
here in the corner
well let's talk about uh all this stuff
let's talk about what's going on uh if
you haven't already smash
that like button hit the notification
bell subscribe we are live
every monday through friday at 8 pm
check us out on itunes spotify leave us
a good review it really does help
but uh so you luke luke you mentioned uh
the uk but let's let's pull up the story
from fox ktv you real quick
coronavirus surge swamping hospitals
prompts indefinite
california lockdown all right they're
gonna they're gonna have to get specific
on that
what do you mean indefinite you mean
people are stuck in their homes forever
they say california's most densely
populated area continues to set new
death and hospitalization records
and will remain under strict stay home
orders for the foreseeable future
as another hospital filing coronavirus
hospital filling
coronavirus surge looms in mere weeks
public health officials said
la county which has recorded 40 percent
of all covet 19 deaths in the state
reported another 227 new deaths on
tuesday although the new daily record
included reporting from holiday backlogs
the country's public health department
also confirmed its highest number of
hospitalizations reported in a day
at more than 7 000 people a nearly 1
000 increase from two months ago
california's top health official dr mark
galley
announced tuesday an extension of the
december 6 lockdown restrictions for the
county
and 22 others in southern california and
the agricultural san joaquin valley
the regions have about 60 percent of the
state's population of 40 million
and also have seen covet 19 surges since
thanksgiving holi since the thanksgiving
holiday
have that have left hospitals struggling
to find beds for emergency room and
intensive care unit patients
some hospitals have set up tents to hold
er patients and
one converted a disused cafeteria to
handle patients
so they're saying indefinite lockdown
all right the first thing is the
constitutional question
how do you do that that clearly violates
our rights as american citizens if
people choose
to go and assemble somewhere they have a
right to do so the constitution doesn't
say unless there's an emergency
by what authority they have to override
that but then the other here's the other
side of that coin
i mean they're giving us some crazy
numbers we got super coveted now
gavin newsom is saying we got the
mutated covet strain
shouldn't we be scared of these things
well we've been hearing about mutant
strains for a while now
first we heard it in the united kingdom
then we heard about
it in south africa then we heard about
it in nigeria but also in april of this
year we heard about 30 other different
strains of the
coronavirus that that that happens i
think they're in los angeles personally
facitiously speaking i think they're
just trying to make sure people don't
escape
before they all get taxed to death and i
think that's why they're well done no
but
they're they're trying to pass that law
where people get taxed
even if they leave the state yeah for uh
years yeah that you're still going to
have to because again they've spent all
their money
and they're in a huge deficit but i
think it's it's pretty clear now
i i think i don't know if you would
agree with me chris that these lockdowns
are kind of counter-intuitive
well they're they're club-ish and and
ham-fisted right so
here's what we've known for a long time
listen i'm i'm not averse to the idea
you say we don't want to swamp our
hospital systems that's not good right
motorcycle victims don't get the
treatment they need cancer patients
can't go in for treatment i get that and
real quick you're a doctor
you're a doctor you have a phd in yes in
a medical i went to duke university and
got a degree in pathology so okay all
right well tell us tell us what's going
on you're the expert
well if you're gonna do a lockdown first
up here's what we know
if i was gonna draw a chart for you i
would say you'd say okay who gets hit by
this who dies
you have an exponentially increasing
risk of death by age
so if you were going to do a lockdown
you'd say we're going to lock down the
old people right not the young people
the chance of dying from this if you're
under the age of
30 is minuscule really really tiny
so i think something a lockdown is
everybody
why is it everybody you would think that
it somewhere along the way you could say
well let's be clever about this let's
take the people with comorbidities let's
take the people who are
immunocompromised let's take the elderly
and let's
keep them safe right that would be part
one if you're just on the subject of
lockdowns which isn't even getting me on
the idea
that we still to this day the nih has
zero
outpatient treatments identified they
just say go home and if you feel worse
come back and if it's bad enough we'll
put you in the hospital that is
literally
as of this morning what was on the nih
website there's actually a good friend
of mine
uh got sick recently i was talking to
him on the phone and they told me that
they went to the doctor doctor told me
they had covered and just go home and
deal with it yep
and they were like uh i don't think i
have covid
like you know they thought they had
strep throat something you know
they've had before and they needed
antibiotics for but the doctor said no
no
we're gonna treat it as covey just go
home and if you get worse then you know
call back and that was it
that's it that's standard of care right
now and it and it's criminal as far as
i'm concerned because there are things
that people can do
so for a quick example we've known since
march vitamin d
it's really more of a hormone but
vitamin d the stuff you get if you go
out into the sun
right which is hard to do in a lockdown
when you're all stuck inside right but
that stuff alone we've had a spanish
study
which showed that of people who were in
critical condition they measured their
blood levels and they said how much
vitamin d do they have
so they discovered that people with
lower than 17 nanograms per ml of
vitamin d in their blood were 80 percent
of their critical covid patients
oh wow nobody with vitamin d above 21
nanograms per mil
was even showing up in their critical
icu so they said wow let's do a study
and they started giving this to people
when they showed up at the hospital and
they cut deaths and they cut
hospitalizations just vitamin d and i
want to make one thing absolutely clear
this is we're not here to give anybody
medical advice you know talk to your
doctor
because you're going to hear a lot of
things from a lot of people in a lot of
different places
we've we've got serious criticism of dr
fauci now because he's changed his
numbers on on
herd immunity he was the one who
initially said you know don't wear masks
so look i'm i'm here to say this i don't
care if you're
left right up down whatever it's your
doctor who knows what's best for you so
take that seriously
and we'll give our opinions yeah and do
your own research do your own homework i
mean i
personally decided to take vitamin d
myself but i know there's a chance of
taking too much of it as well exactly
and i know that you should also get your
blood
tested to make sure that your levels are
normal and not
either too low or too high because if
you even if it's too high it could be
dangerous for you and one of the one of
the big issues i think we see that
sort of exacerbates a lot of censorship
is that
people will go online and they'll learn
about something maybe even like vitamin
d and then they might
take too much that's why i talk to your
doctor your doctor is going to know
better than we will about you
so but anyway i digress well even dr
fauci admitted he finally that he's
taking vitamin d on his own
right and he but he said that to
jennifer garner so he might have been a
little starstruck he was on her blog
vlog right and she said what are you
taking he said well i'm taking vitamin d
you know and so here's the you know the
peop the person that people are
nominally looking to the most
right yeah what is the downside for
somebody like that to say here's what
i'm doing
you might consider it too but talk to
your doctor yeah and well i i i want to
make sure i pull this up
dr fauci from cnbc.com is recommending
vitamin d
so there you go yeah he could have done
that in march he could have done that
that would have been nice this is
september
you know the scary thing is there hasn't
been a conversation about
health there hasn't been a conversation
about vitamins about diets about
exercise about sleep about stress about
exercise
there hasn't been real conversations
about things that actually matter that
will have a huge tremendous effect on
what we're dealing with right now that's
fat shaming
okay yeah okay and and ableist i made a
video about the fatties
uh today not people are gonna like that
but i think it's important to bring up
the reality of the situation so people
understand what they're getting
themselves yes obesity was a big factor
and obesity is dramatically going up in
the united states
some would say as a byproduct of the
industry buying off the government and
of course
implementing a lot of policies that have
been very hurtful and it's kind of
strange that now a government that
absolutely
had what industry though i mean we're
talking about industries like monsanto
and the fast food industry and the sugar
industry when you look at their impact
on the market when you look at their
impact on human life you see a huge
i would say in my opinion a detrimental
impact that should be addressed
should be should be uh they should be
held accountable for but the larger
point that i'm
was trying to kind of point to and make
here is that we're kind of left in the
dark
and and we don't know what to do because
when you even talk about this stuff you
risk
getting censored and banned which is
absolutely ridiculous and you know why
the way the the the censorship works
it's not like there's a doctor at
youtube who's got like a checklist of
the appropriate response
cdc guidelines going like what did he
talk about he talked about that's okay
we approve of that we prove it
no it's like some 20 year old dude going
like he's talking about
medicine like he's not a doctor i'm
going to ban this even when you
are a doctor even doctors are getting
banned
didn't you get hit or something like
that i did i i got a youtube strike
and um and you're you're not a medical
are you a medical doctor no you're not
no
but you have a doctor but you have a
doctorate in pathology yeah and i'm i'm
eminently qualified to read reports and
analyze them but
in this case all i was doing there was a
senate testimony of a board-certified
doctor who's in critical care dr corey
he was giving senate testimony basically
that this the headline of it is
i can't keep doing this anymore those
are his words and he what he
what he meant was he couldn't watch
people come into his critical care
pulmonary center and die
because he knew they didn't have to
because he'd seen all this data all this
data coming in from all over the world
saying there are
things we can do and that was his
testimony so i thought well let me
review that for people and
that's all i did i reviewed a
board-certified doctor's testimony but
that was deemed medical disinformation i
think there's a
if i were to if i were to take like a
simple uh like if i was to assume the
simple reason as to why
youtube is so incredi and incredibly
sensorious is that they're scared of the
media
because when this all started when the
wall street journal smeared pewdiepie
then all of a sudden their advertisers
just dropped off and youtube already is
burning a hole in the pocket of google
losing money
so they're just like whatever the media
says will do
and so you get activists in media who
will find any reason to accuse you of
wrongdoing
and they they've even removed rand paul
was giving a speech on the senate floor
on c-span youtube billy did it
youtube took the video down because oh
no we can't have that they're they're
more worried about the negative public
perception from media companies
than allowing people to have this
conversation to hear this testimony was
the doc dr corey said his name was
yeah dr corey he was testifying to
congress
and you that that's that's not that's
not that's not allowed anymore i guess
so we we we're we're you know i kind of
feel like it's like i don't know if you
guys ever see one of those cartoons
where they're
they're on a mountain side like driving
on a road along a cliff and then the car
is like turning and the wheels are on
the edge
that's what that's what we're kind of
getting into getting into here but you
know hey whatever so be it
well you saw rand paul's dad ron paul
got a ding he got a
youtube strike really well it's uh i'm
sorry it's uh uh
ron paul's son rand paul ron paul's the
original i know ron paul the original
yeah yes the original talking about
covid
he he covered a trump rally and he also
got dinged
with medical disinformation as the ding
he's literally a doctor
i know he was an ob gyn right yeah i
love
it what and it's it's crazy man
breitbart
filmed this is amazing breitbart was
rated
was certified as uh credible by
newsguard which is like a microsoft
funded you know
news credibility rating system but then
they filmed a press conference
put on by a republican representative
and some doctors and that was deemed
enough to
strike them down as not credible they
didn't even say anything
they just filmed other people talking at
the capitol with a politician but but
this is this is the bigger problem here
that we
really need to realize the official line
that they're going with
keeps flip-flopping every week whether
it's the world health organization or
the cdc they literally contradict
themselves
so many times and haven't come out with
any concrete
legitimate information that has been
consistent i don't know about
you but i have a very hard time thinking
that a government that never gave a damn
about my health
somehow now is it's their number one
priority i think there's a lot of room
to be skeptical here
but again there's no consistency here we
don't know what the official line is
because it keeps changing
i don't think the government cares about
anything i i think there's one thing
collectively that's on the minds of
politicians and bureaucrats it's
what will i do that's over the line that
results in torches and pitchforks
that's the thing right that's the like
it's are the people going to protest and
ramble because protests
mostly i'll tell you this nonviolence of
disobedience works but
i don't think they care anymore because
the way i described it uh you know
earlier this year you're only allowed to
say bad things
there's no conversation where we can be
like hey we have good news a doctor said
these things it's positive it's it's
upbeat
it's it's a lighting into the tunnel
they ban you for it they ban you for it
you talk about
this country brought up these treatments
so trump is crazy he's wrong he's lying
i would say i could say something like
uh you know techcrunch reported that
zpac you know uh hydroxychloroquine was
showing promising results in a french
study
and then a smear piece comes out
claiming you know using
using twisted framing timpool claims
that studies prove blah blah but that's
not true
even though it's like you know they'll
try and make sure you can't say anything
positive
so what ends up happening is all the
news that comes out is super covet is
here
hospitals are overrun everyone's you
know sick and dying it's getting worse
it's worse it's worse it's worse
and so then everyone just keeps getting
more and more scared
and that results in the snowball rolling
down the hill of the story only going
crazier and crazier
because imagine this right now what we
know
is there are many hospitals that are
being overrun we see the photos and the
videos of the nurses there and they're
like their faces and they're like the
marks on their face from the ppe and
they're tired and they're beating their
hair's all messed up
most hospitals is my understanding are
actually okay
there's tons of videos of hospitals that
have not been you know overrun and
that's because hot spots are centralized
in certain areas
but we're not getting video after video
after video of hospitals that are okay
we're getting video after video after
video of hospitals they're doing
worse and then we're getting videos of
nurses dancing i guess that's kind of
the positive i suppose
glad they have time for that right yeah
yeah yeah but
the main point i'm trying to make is if
the only thing you ever hear and are
allowed to hear
is that things are getting worse you'll
you you don't actually know
like there's no balance to this
conversation are we go
is there is there a chance for optimism
can't tell you that because we'll be
censored if we do
that's where we're at yeah and as a
scientist this actually bothers me a lot
this whole idea that there is
a central body that there's an
agreed-upon set of facts that we know we
don't know crap about this at this point
in time right so here what we know it's
a novel
corona can i even say this you know yeah
yeah i can i can say
so it's novel which means we have to try
some things right and the whole thing
about
the dr corey in his testimony he said
look we don't need the latest whiz-bang
stuff out of farmer that would be great
but we have a hundred years of medical
and medicine development and we have
things that work and by the way we try
things all the time
off label we try things in for other
things and they work all the time in
fact
we do all sorts of off-label stuff
already with kids you give them like you
know ssris and all that stuff that's off
label right don't
aren't there like medications that have
a side effect of weight loss that they
prescribe to people to lose weight like
is there stuff like that too that's off
label right yeah
and and everything has a side effect you
know everything water
take too much you have a side effects
but i would just think that at some
point this whole idea
we can't have that positive news isn't
the nation just like ready for some of
that relief
wouldn't they be just wouldn't everybody
just be kicking their heels up if we
said
we can there's something that some
doctors are saying is really effective
and by the way there's a lot of them
that's better than go home and come back
to the hospital if you feel worse
if it bleeds it leads so lady just
pulled this up this is from fortune.com
u.s
news coverage of covet has been more
negative than in other countries
researchers find
that so and that's a fact like you
mentioned you got you you took you got a
a strike
right on youtube and and uh ron paul did
as well and you
are a a phd in a pathologist and
rand paul is literally a doctor well i
should say he's retired
but uh man how crazy is that so
i started reporting again january 23rd
within a couple of weeks maybe a week
and a half or so my wiki page which had
been up for over a decade got yanked
got taken down and the complaint was
that i was talking about things that was
that were out of my wheelhouse that i
had no authority that in fact
i wasn't a practicing scientist and all
this stuff now i'm a published scientist
and and it's true i've been doing other
things besides you know conducting
science for a while
but that doesn't invalidate the training
or the degree or what i know right they
have have
uh the papers that you've gotten
published in scientific journals been
invalidated or
don't move so it's all it's all
currently standing science it is yes
well this happens in many different
instances in many different kind of
areas for me personally they got me
because i didn't believe in the russian
collusion
after donald trump's victory when he
first won the presidency
and they delisted me they de-personed me
on wikipedia and said that this is a
person that shouldn't even be mentioned
or referenced no matter what he does no
matter what news he's
trying so hard just to give himself i'll
tell you there there's been
uh a lot of attempts at
somehow finding a way to smear me
because i'm so i'm i'm as i'm like i've
fairly boring you know tepid commentary
for the most part but
uh there was an article i read from fox
business about seth rich
and then there was a statement from
kitten.com they claimed that by talking
about it and arguing that it wasn't
definitive
i was pushing a conspiracy theory and
then nbc writes that and
airs on tv i'm a conspiracy theorist
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
other outlets just repeat it without any
basis any fact checking any sourcing at
all
even though i'm the one who's constantly
reigning on all these all the parades of
these people saying it's probably not
true outcomes razor simple solution and
i don't believe in any of this stuff
doesn't matter they need to find a way
to discredit you and take you down
i'm surprised that right deleted your
wikipedia page that's that's bold but
that's one way to do it
because no one's i think one of the
issues is who's going to write negative
things about you and what's their
grounds to do it
right you're you're a published
scientist giving your thoughts and
opinions
quick get rid of them because if they
can't smear you and find a way to do it
they have to just get rid of you right
right so i wasn't big enough to
to not be gotten rid of right you have
to be big enough so that it makes too
much of a stink you know so i think
already by early february this means
that there was a very serious attempt at
message control
and my view was remember at the time of
like new york times watching poster all
saying oh it's just the flu it's no
worse than the flu and i was like no
this is totally different here's some of
the
virology behind it this thing has got a
lot of keys into the human locks
and it's a little bizarre and i was
saying we need to take this really
seriously
and at the time i was totally in
conflict with the who because they were
saying
well we shouldn't shut down travel and
that's i was just reading their own
pandemic handbook that's what i was
sourcing from and i was saying no that's
actually
step one you you stop travel of course
you do even george washington when he
was facing a huge outbreak of smallpox
first thing he did was he stopped people
traveling to and from his army didn't
right
didn't he write letters telling people
to get vaccinated too
were like they had some like that little
stick thing that they could yeah yeah
yeah there was like a letter going
around where george washington was
apparently like get the smallpox vaccine
that was my first moment i'm a scientist
i'm trying to share data i think this is
interesting it could help people get
prepared you know i was telling people
get ppe
n95 mass way before they got sold out
all that but then i'm confused i'm like
how is the who getting like its own
handbook for this wrong
and then my wikipedia page gets taken
down and then i've just run
my youtube subscriber count was just
skyrocketing and it leveled off the day
i mentioned hydroxychloroquine it's been
literally plus or minus one thousand
for eight months it's just it's just
flat it's 365
000 that's the just flat works man yep
well we also have to remember during
that specific time it wasn't just the
world health organization going against
their own guidelines
it was also many politicians in the
mainstream media saying it's xenophobic
to stop travel yes that it's racist to
stop traveling
and then politicians told you to go to
the chinese day parade and to go
celebrate
to show that everyone's not racist come
on down to chinatown yeah be racist
so so here's where this all leads us to
because you know i don't want to we we
talk a lot about the hypocrisy and stuff
it leads to people finally having enough
we got the stories from the daily mail
50 maskless anti-lockdown protesters
force their way into
la supermarket after california extends
regional stay-at-home order indefinitely
amid 1 000 spike in hospitalizations
they say police responded to calls
about an unruly crowd at the arawan
market in la's fairfax district on
tuesday afternoon
dozens of massless people were filmed
shoving their way into the store
the protesters berated staffers
demanding that they cover their faces
with
what we just want to shop we want to
take our own precautions that we've been
doing all our lives
and we'll all be fine an organizer of
the demonstration said the incident came
as governor gavin newsom extended state
home order
in the southern california region l.a
county has become one of the nation's
worst hot
hot spots in recent weeks
hospitalizations in the country in the
county have grown tenfold in the last
two months so check out this photo
i mean you guys can't see it but uh for
those that are that are watching you can
it says a crowd of about 50 massless
anti-lockdown protesters
shoving their way into a store you got a
lot of people man
i'll tell you i don't know i don't know
if you remember seeing the videos from
earlier in the year of the stores being
stripped clean i mean first of all
toilet paper was the first to go
i think my favorite video was when
everyone runs full speed and they're
wrestling over toilet paper
it's so weird man like if you're worried
i guess they weren't worried about the
pandemic they're just worried about
wiping their butts
for real all right you know what i i'd
run for the food in the bottled water
like if i if everyone runs breaks with
toilet paper i'm gonna i'm gonna go get
some produce and some canned
goods i don't know but anyway i digress
the other day we heard a lady
beat a cop with her own baton because
she was told to wear a mask
a navy vet bashed a guy at a bar over
the head with a bottle for being told to
wear a mask
now you've got these people storming
their way into a supermarket saying we
want to shop
so what happens when people start
running out of food
because it's going to happen i mean
people aren't working
california's making the lockdown crazier
you combine that with the hypocrisy
you combine that with people who who
earlier in the year were saying one
thing and doing another
and now they've flipped 18 180 and if
you repeat the same thing
the surgeon general said earlier this
year about masks or fauci did
or they'll nuke you they'll get rid of
your account they'll get rid of your
channel
if you say it's xenophobic to ban travel
oh you're gone but they said all of that
when they decide it when when and it's
not even republicans it's
it's mostly democrats when they decide
to say it's fine no matter what it is
they say
that's where we're at right now people
can see that you know you've got
uh uh murphy in new jersey went out to
eat and got got got harassed by or you
got berated by some people
you've got whitmer went to get her hair
cut you know lori lightfoot
you've got nancy pelosi you got newsome
violating coveted lockdowns
i wonder these people their loved ones
are dying
they can't go out and they can't see
them they can't be in the hospital with
them their children are being born can't
be in the hospital with them either
i've seen tons of comments for people
saying you know my parent or you know
grandparent has been in the hospital
with cancer or some illness and it's
been weeks and they're deteriorating no
one can see them or visit them
and then what do we get the politicians
are breaking their own rules
dr burks on the the task force violates
covid restrictions that she's the advice
she's given goes visits her family
takes photos and then insult to injury
the nurses get on
on camera and choreograph dances and
shuffle about
in a place where people are dying in
mess eventually i think the people are
going to kick the doors into the
supermarket just start taking stuff
and it's probably going to get crazier
than that people are going to start
just this law is going to start breaking
down yeah i mean it already is
well there's a when i'm talking with
somebody and and we're sharing opinions
people can get you know passionate about
it but still you're just met with
an opinion doesn't really go off the
rails when you're talking about it but
when somebody's beliefs are challenged
emotions flare up so i think what's
actually happening is these people are
finally discovering
that you know we held a belief that
we're a country we're a country of
people we're decent we're hard working
we have this american dream story right
and that our our leaders
are really there for us you know in some
way i guess went deep down but but this
is
koba to strip something bare which is
that our leaders don't care at
all about us and probably the most
shocking grotesque display and there
have been many
has to be this most recent stimulus bill
right six
hundred dollars for everybody earning 75
grand or less right
so that you added up that's about 90
billion dollars out of 900 that's 10
percent going to people
right who have been out of work for
months after months after months after
months so what do you do with 600 bucks
after you've been out of work for
you know eight months not a lot right do
you pay your your overdue cable bill or
your cell phone or what do you do with
that right
and then they put 90 percent of that
goes to like
israel and well one year 1.3 billion is
going to egypt 700 million is going to
sudan
453 million is going to ukraine and then
500 million is going to israel
so there so uh to just clarify 200
billion
of the 2.3 trillion omnibus is going to
be disbursed as stimulus payments
the next 700 there's 700 uh
i'm sorry is that 200 billion and then
there's 700 billion that's going to be
dispersed in other
kinds of like uh economic relief like
the paycheck protection program and
things like that
then you get the omnibus spending bill
which was a ton of it is like
general spending programs but a lot of
them are ridiculous like what's the
what's the lizards on on treadmills or
whatever
and the pakistani gender programs i
don't care
what the number is you know we're we're
at a point where
our economy has been decimated when
we're unable to work and survive
why would you give any money could you
imagine let me just give you an analogy
could you imagine you get fired from
your job right
and you've got a savings of a couple
grand and your rent is like a thousand
bucks a month and you're like well i
could probably last about two months
i'm gonna give my money my neighbor he
seems hungry or you're gonna be like i'm
gonna give away a thousand dollars of my
money for my savings so my neighbor can
take a gender studies class at a local
college
who in their right mind would do that
when they print when they said a 2.3
trillion we're going to get
does that mean that we are going to
borrow 2.3 trillion from the federal
reserve
um it so the run rate of their spend
right now is is
a run rate on an annualized basis close
to 10 trillion
and total income is around four so
they're spending
not all of that will be borrowed some of
that comes in in income taxes something
comes into social security taxes
fico stuff like that but but by far the
the majority of it's being borrowed
right now
do you know what how much of it's being
borrowed but about who is it borrowed
from how do they borrow it
well the treasury conducts an auction
and this is a very simple magician trick
right um the federal reserve is not
directly monetizing debt because that
would be banana republic so what happens
is
one of the 23 primary dealers jp morgan
uh et cetera they go in and they buy
these things and then the federal
reserve buys it from them
and of course they take a little cut you
know a little skim couple basis points
to take a little vig so that's how it
works but if you follow the action the
federal reserve is literally buying
fresh u.s paper
the same day in many cases right so it's
it's just it's just one step to make it
look like it's not what it is which is
the federal reserve prints money out of
thin air and our government
spends it yeah so it sounds like a ponzi
scheme well so what's the long-term
effect of that
the long-term effect is is money is
let's be clear money is just a it's a
it's a social agreement
it's just a it's it's a claim on
something there's you know that the the
paper in luke's notebook you know we say
is just paper but this other paper has
value or these ones and zeros on this
hard disk mean this but not that over
there
so money is just this thing that we all
agree has value
the long-term effect of just printing
printing printing is you take from
everybody by last time i went to the
grocery store first time i ever had a
500
grocery bill right and i could easily
carry the whole thing
right and they tell me constantly
there's no inflation
but i know there is and my health care
which i have to buy as a small business
owner
it goes up reliably 10 20 every year
let me tell everybody a trick you can do
right now go on amazon.com
select some electronics put them into
your cart
and then don't buy them close the
browser come back in a week
you'll get a notification happen to me i
was going to buy a tablet
and i forgot opened it up a day or two
later and it said price change 500 to
650.
the cost went up to clarify how we're
borrowing this money so the
the us government will be like we're
going to borrow a trillion from the
federal reserve but what they'll do is
the federal reserve will loan a trillion
to jp morgan or one of 23
banks middlemen and then the bank will
loan it to the u.s government
not not exactly like that um so the
federal the treasury department
puts out let's say a trillion dollars of
treasury bills right three-year notes
five-year notes 10-year notes whatever
they are 30-day bills but they put a
trillion bucks out
and then people bid for them in these
competitive auctions
almost all of that goes to these big
banks the big banks are buying it with
cash they have kicking around most of
which they got from the federal reserve
different mechanism
but that's real cash and then the
federal reserve takes real cash and
wires it into their accounts and takes
those
assets those debt instruments off their
hands so the federal reserve is holding
a bunch of u.s
treasury bills yeah a ton trillions and
we default on that
um not if you have a printing press it's
very hard to do so
so this is this is what what has really
been running and it's going to hit
everybody really hard and i think it's
going to hit us really bad in the next
few years and it's a direct consequence
of all this printing and it's this
the federal reserve my statement about
them is they're what i call a reverse
robin hood organization
they print a lot of money the people who
get their hands on it first do something
called the cantalon effect
if you're closest to it like if i'm the
federal reserve luke you're sitting
there and i print a bunch a trillion
dollars you get it first because you're
the big bank in line
you then spend that on whatever you want
and by the time it trickles out to the
rest of the people stakes are you know
18 a pound and whatever right because of
that
what happens is you find that as a
little person your bank account
it doesn't buy as much anymore your
purchasing power went away
but where'd it go that's the where'd it
go that's the mechanism the mandrake
mechanism
the the sleight of hand so everybody in
the nation all 320 million lose a little
bit of purchasing power from
their bank accounts but it's it's an
economic axiom it had to go
somewhere where did it go if you follow
the story it went to the billionaires
the trillionaires
the the elites they got all of that so
that's why i call the federal reserve
the reverse robin hood because they take
from the many
to give to the few and when you look at
the purchase that makes people pissed
off oh yeah when they realize what's
going on because sadly a lot of people
don't realize what's going on and
they're like yes government
give me my six hundred dollars or my two
thousand dollars immediately and they
think it literally comes out of thin air
it doesn't
you pay for it in one way or another
your children are going to be paying for
it
and if you look at the purchasing power
of the dollar from 10 years ago
20 years ago 30 years ago you will be
absolutely shocked to understand how
fast
the value of the dollars going down even
just recently as you mentioned in the
supermarket i'm even seeing it and it's
it's uh scary stuff i remember when i
was a kid and a candy bar cost 40 cents
i know dude i used to buy penny candy
yeah
sell it for five cents in front of my
house yeah it works yep then they went
up to two cents
i remember that they went from it's one
cent to two cents in like the course of
a year and then they were five cents
that's that's that's that's influence
that's a hundred percent so so think
about this important
the important thing to understand about
this is if you make 10 bucks an hour
with inflation with this mass printing
of money we've effectively just lowered
the minimum wage
basically in terms of buying power of
course everybody's value is stripped
even the business owners
the another way to look at it is let's
say you worked for 50 years
or you know what yeah 40 40 some odd
years you finally retired
and you got a couple hundred grand in
your retirement account well you're not
going to make
more that's your money that's your
budget for the rest of your life
and then they mass print trillions of
dollars devaluing that currency also in
your retirement account
is worth half of what it was no longer
enough to actually retire on what do you
do
i guess a lot of people are going to
become dependent on the government to
keep printing money for them because the
money they have is no longer sound
enough to actually buy things
so then you get people who work at
walmart because walmart gets special
kickbacks from government
walmart then pays their employees trash
their employees then have to get
government benefits and
around and around but the government's
not even printing it it's the it's the
federal reserve a private company is
printing it for us so
and then we give them we give them notes
of like
we promise to give you the money back
right that's what these are
if we were to default on that and say
you know what federal reserve we can't
we're not what would happen
well the whole system breaks at that
point in time the whole world the whole
world breaks
the petrol dollar so so it's not just we
the people who
who are on the hook for those treasury
notes right so we owe a bunch of those
to china china holds
1.3 trillion dollars of them there's
about seven trillion dollars of u.s
obligations out there in the world it's
a big number a trillion is a big
number this is the crazy thing what that
really means and correct if i'm wrong
that china has guaranteed access to u.s
labor
right that's ultimately what the money
would get them something produced or
a service provided by an american
they're getting so it's effectively like
when the u.s borrows money from china to
pay back with interest
they're saying this cur that what we're
going to give you assures that the
people in our country will work for you
in some capacity is that the chinese
central bank that we owe
yes that that's who's nominated version
of the federal reserve
yeah with the people's bank of china um
and then there's the bank of
uh well the the so are you familiar with
the bank of international settlements
the bank so that's like the the mother
central bank where all the other central
banks funnel their money through
um i would imagine that the bank of
china and the federal reserve
are connected through the bank for
international settlements
yeah and i don't know that it's useful
really to think about different
countries when you get to the banking
or cartels you know they're really a
tribe you know
they hang out together and i'm not
really clear what the difference is
between
all the member banks at the bis and
because i don't know that they have
sovereign interests
but is it really like how you just
explained they do things on paper to
make it seem like it's legitimate when
in reality they just control whether
you get access to resources or not yeah
so um
i give a lot of talks right and i've
i've been in front of i'm guessing ten
thousand different audience members at
this point in time and i always ask this
one question
i say particularly u.s audiences i say
how many of you ever learned about how
money is created in the system
i watched zeitgeist i've had two hands
go up
that whole time like taught in school
right one was at a crazy marxist
professor at umass another was it
oberlin economics professor again a nut
but you can teach this to fifth graders
and i know because i have and once you
teach people how money is created in the
system
because this whole idea that the federal
reserve has money no they don't they
just literally click on a keyboard
and it's created in that moment it's
digital isn't it yes it's all digital
not even paper
not even that like when you go and
borrow money from a bank people thinking
like jimmy stewart it's a wonderful life
and you go down and your savings are in
my
mortgage it's not like that at all when
i go to a bank and i take out a mortgage
they click on keyboards again
and when i borrow say 400 000 to buy a
house they just
that's when it got created that's when
the 400 000 came into poof bm
now here's the easiest way to i break
down to people why it's a problem
because i i've got a bunch of these you
know lefty friends
who are like you know we need this two
thousand dollar stimulus bill and i'm
like i hear you i hear you you do i get
it i get it
you're gonna get evicted your job has
been taken away from you but i think the
real issue is that they've taken away
your ability to provide for yourself
so i try to explain to them why it's a
problem we're putting all this money and
i'll put it very simply
there's there's five of us here in this
room imagine
there was one dollar between the five of
us
and i'd give it to luke and then luke
would trade it to ian and ian would
trade it and that's how the economy
functioned
now imagine one day i show up and i
start drawing on a piece of paper
dollars i'm doing no work i'm trading
nothing for anybody
and i'm convincing all of you to give me
your stuff because i drew a picture
that's basically what's happening
we're all as the work as working people
doing something in exchange for a good
so that we can provide for each other
resources and then
the government basically comes in and
says oh i did work here's my money too
and we go oh thank you government but
they didn't they just drew it on a piece
of paper they typed it on the keyboard
and pressed enter
and we're giving away our stuff to
people who aren't working on our for us
or with us
or trading with us so we're using their
money pictures
and the payment for that is we got to
give them interest for it
and what is interest in this story do
you think what what is that
percentage of the picture uh like
i said one so to me if you're the bank
and you loan me that 400 000
mortgage and i pay it back to you that
money was created and it's given back
but where did the interest come from in
this story what does that represent
well what it represents is my labor over
time so over the next 30 years if i have
a mortgage i borrowed 400 i might pay
800 back depending on the rate of
interest
where did that 400 000 come from well it
came from my hard work but when you
created that 400 thousand what'd you do
you went clickity clickety click
that was the total work yes in that
story but
me i'm doing 30 more years in a garage
and as a bus driver is whatever whatever
right um
so that's this that's why it's never
taught in school
because once you learn that you go that
doesn't feel right
it's one big ponzi scheme with these
individuals providing absolutely no
value at all banking wall street they're
the only industry that literally is the
only people that don't actually produce
something of a service don't actually
produce a good
they just literally make it out of thin
air right that's that's that's
absolutely wrong luke you are wrong
they provide excellent source material
for movies like the wolf of wall street
okay that was a
great awesome it was awesome with
matthew mcconaughey and he's pounding on
his chest uh they used that's awesome
see if it wasn't for these guys would we
be entertained they used to execute
bankers for
charging interest they called it usually
it was a it was a capital punish
capital crime to commit usury which was
to charge interest on the loan
but you know honestly 1700s 1800s or
something
i personally have no issue if i've got
10 bucks and i say okay i can front you
the money now but i want back eleven
dollars
i mean if i'm actually giving you taking
that risk giving a flat
interest rate is different than a
compounding interest rate
i want that back plus ten percent is
different than saying plus one percent
every month until you pay me back
well look if i i think if someone enters
into a contract it's their choice
if i have money if i say look i'm gonna
lend you this you know half bottle of
water but you got to give me a full
bottle of water when you know in a month
or so
i think i'm fine with that the problem
is when i'm like okay
um i'm not actually going to give you
any real water i'm going to spit in a
bottle call it water and then you got to
give me a full body
full bottle of water back but even with
the spitting what you're doing there is
you're actually doing something
right right right even spinning his work
so so you're doing something
that's the difference here and and so
the idea of like if i earn ten dollars
because of my hard labor and then i
decide to loan 10 to luke and and you
know he's going to pay me back 11.
that's a different story from saying i'm
going to create 10 out of thin air
and then insist that you give it all
back plus
whatever the particularly compounding
interest right so so that's the game
and by the way that game is going to
unravel
in everybody's lifetime here mine yours
everybody
this is this is the story that's coming
apart because it made a lot of sense in
a time when you could just continue to
grow exponentially forever that's what
we've been doing on this planet
and our money system is no different
it's just compounding compounding
more and more and more debt now it's
kind of on that steep phase you know you
look at the
pull up a chart of like us government
debt it is well i've written yeah yeah
i've got uh st louis fed.org economic
research
money stock have you seen this yeah it
just goes up and then look at this
in 2020 it goes from uh you can see yeah
beginning of the year
it just skyrockets billions of dollars
jumps from 4
000 to 7 000. so it's like
4 trillion to 7 trillion right yeah but
but that increase that's a 66
increase in 12 months so all the money
used in this country for 66
in one year because the last time we
talked about is that 35. yeah that
well now they're printing more there's
more this is m1 you're looking at
probably which is which is demand
that's uh checking savings plus currency
right but think about that
every dollar created in our country was
about 800 billion
up till before the first great financial
crisis right every bridge every war
fought every school
every everything took 800 billion of
money stock creation then they doubled
that
in about a year and that's that model
has just been going and you can feel
it's getting faster and faster so for
all your listeners out there
just ask yourself is it does it feel
like it's just speeding up
yup because it actually is so uh so
bitcoin
i i mean those charts look similar to
the bitcoin charts uh
especially i have a i have a phone
with uh you know it has a bitcoin wallet
on it and it's an old phone so i just
was like at one point i was like
whatever you know just put it in a box
and forgot about it
and then i i'm following max kaiser on
uh on twitter you guys know max you know
that's right
orange pill podcast and he's he's got
this really funny meme
where he says have fun staying poor have
you seen that
people people who keep telling him
bitcoin was like don't buy bitcoin it's
crazy doesn't make sense
it's him sitting in a chair like looking
at the camera says have fun staying poor
and so i'm seeing him post these things
and then all of a sudden i'm like people
saying bitcoin broke it's all-time high
and i'm like where's that phone hit and
i'm like trying to figure out where it
is and it's dead and i gotta plug it in
to see like what's still on it because
it's 28 000
for one coin couple of years ago well
this is the thing
three thousand dollars people are
looking for alternatives to the dollar
people are looking to get out of this
thing that of course people are just
printing like
crazy and that's why we're seeing i
think in one instance why
cryptocurrencies are doing so well right
now because of this
incredible amount of money let me let me
let me tell you
i think crypto is not the right call i
think gold is not the right call if
there's one thing you got to buy it's
primal youth by dr jones spinning
infowars.com no no no no water
access to water watching that video of
these people storm through
this supermarket because of the
lockdowns and they're like we want food
like we want to shop you can have all
the bitcoin in the world when an angry
mob is hungry they're not going to stop
to ask you for your for your for your
private you know or for your public key
or whatever to do in exchange
they're gonna they're gonna punch in the
face and take your sandwich of course
that's why i bought ammo heirloom seeds
a lot of medicine that we can't even
mention on this show right now
uh you know being prepared and having
you know personal responsibility is the
absolute key and when you're paying
attention when you know
you know big companies like citadel and
blackrock and you see the revolving door
you see the game that's being played on
the american people
and you see the writing on the wall it's
there and it's becoming
way more and more evident and when the
people who are writing are going to find
out about the exact details
i don't know oh boy i don't know what's
going to happen you guys see this video
out of new york where the kids are
smashing the suv
yeah throwing their bikes at one one kid
you know runs up jumps and then drop
kicks the windshield it was a medical
suv apparently
new york is look it's a way i'll i'm
gonna call it a wasteland because i'm
being hyperbolic but let me tell you
something
what people don't understand about
extreme circumstances that you're a frog
in a pot with the water level
the heat slowly rising until the water
boils and you don't realize it
think about what you were doing in new
york a couple years ago compared to what
you can do in new york now and you might
be like oh that's kind of crazy
can't do any of that anymore when was
the last time you saw a story about a
mob of people breaking into a
supermarket
new york city is it's you know their
street races at night now i'm seeing
these videos of people just speeding
through the empty streets yeah crazy
then driving around manhattan because
it's it's a wasteland
and i look obviously it's not like a
desolate a post-apocalyptic fallout
you know stop style you know you know
junkyard or whatever there's people
walking around living their normal lives
but in many ways
it's it's a fraction of what it used to
be to the point where these kids can
ride around their bikes smash windows
and just
there's nothing anyone can do about it
so that's happening now what's going to
happen
when the value of the dollar goes even
lower
so this when there's a whole bunch of
unprepared people that don't have
resources that don't know what to do
that don't have a plan
are stuck without any of the important
things coming in and this is what i'm
saying
if right now in new york teenagers on
bikes can just
attack an suv and you get away with it
and and we see people just driving
around manhattan
it's lawlessness what do you think
happens if the police can't handle
what's going on right now
you know ruffian teenagers smash in a
car how do you think they're going to
handle
pockets of 50 to 100 people in different
parts of the city smashing their way
into supermarkets screaming we want to
shop we need food
the cops are going to go i can't do
anything about it sorry if they can't
handle this now
you do not want to be in a city like
that i can't believe there are people
who are staying there too and they
didn't handle it they didn't handle it
in uh during the summer of this year
during the black lives matter protest
when they were just standing around not
doing anything having their little
uh protest against actually doing their
job
so when it came to when the people
needed them the most when there was
rioting when there was looting when
there was actual violence in the street
they literally just stood back and
watched everything happen yeah they did
nothing
so i think we're getting dangerously
close to that point where
you know i was talking i got talking to
my lefty friends trying to explain to
them the problem
of mass printing with what were they
nearly doubled the money supply was 66
increase that's crazy and uh you know
we did a segment about it and it was we
got a ton of views on it because people
are like
they're seeing that spike in the money
stock and they're like what does that
mean that looks scary
like because you have all of this 200
years of slow and steady increase and
then
straight up so so but just wrap up my
point real quick talking to my lefty
friend i bring this up and i'm like
what does that mean for you i don't know
20 uh for a gallon of milk
15 bucks for a gallon of gas at some
point right if the money stock has just
doubled
the inflation is coming soon read your
history man read about all these
countries whether where the
hyperinflation happened
and the mass printing of money resulted
in people shoveling bills into the
dumpster
what you were saying so i agree with all
of that and
um this problem definition that we're up
against i mean it's so so first up that
chart
seeing the m1 the money supply just
spike listen keep a journal i mean this
is
crazy times this is the hard part i want
to shake people buy the lapels i want to
slap them
you know airplane style wake up because
this is insane what's happening right
now it's literally insane and if you
can't decode the signal
so if this is an easy signal 66 increase
in the money supply
trust me we're going to get people like
when's this inflation gonna show up like
it's already here but the inflation
goes where the money goes so they
printed all that money they mostly gave
it to rich people so what are rich
people like they like
jewels art yachts gulf streams
trophy properties stocks and bonds all
of those are through the roof right now
we're seeing all that the pricing on
that if you can even find a lot of this
stuff
so you held up water this is what my
company is a company t-shirt we're all
about resilience and so the problem
definition side is like yeah this stuff
is happening how much convincing do you
need once you're past convincing
what do you do about it yeah you know
that's what we need to be talking about
what do you do about this because
already where i live in western mass all
the properties got snapped up
all the just a fraction of a percent of
people leaving new york in boston said
that was enough to kill our real estate
market yep and when you i get a lot of
questions specifically with people
asking me
when will the great reset happen unlike
it's here it's here
it's happening right now in front of our
very eyes and no one's even paying
attention and realizing
that it's the largest transfer of wealth
is happening right in front of their
eyes
john kerry came out he has a big
position inside of
the biden administration he came out and
said of course the biden administration
is going to go along with the great
reset we're going to implement it
quicker and faster than anyone could
even imagine
but yes people forget we're here we're
at this juncture right now the great
reset people this is you know klaus
schwab and the whole davos crowd the
world economic forum
one of their key catchphrases they've
been marketing for years is build back
better
build back better build all across
europe and they had it recently we saw
trudeau out of canada
and boris johnson and and uh you've got
biden talking about it but the funny
thing is if you go to the biden harris
transition website it doesn't say
bidenharris transition.gov
their website is literally
buildbackbetter.gov that is their
transition the talking points websites
so this that's what these european
leaders
that's their slogan why is there a dot
gov that's a slogan of
european leaders why is it the the
president-elect's
website build back better what does that
even mean first off it's
it's sort of a just grammatically it's
kind of a disaster but
is it like once once it falls apart
we're going to make it stronger again so
like if an animal's suffering you want
to put it out of its misery is that what
they're trying to do right now is
is put the system out of its misery so
that we can come back stronger
everything's being destroyed and they're
going to build
back better but better there you go yeah
they're better they're just
i needed the right emphasis exactly it
feels good redefine
capitalism to make everything more equal
and more fair for everyone
you know the big powerful globalists
that are responsible for so many ills
and wrongs in the world
are now going to have a 180 degree flip
in their
soul and actually start doing good
things for everyone just like they
promise in this very vague open language
that we hear
on the on the the imf the world bank so
i just want the world economic forum
i i do want to make sure we we we cite
all this we have the hill john kerry
reveals biden's devotion to radical gree
great reset movement now to to be to
clarify this is from a contributor
justin haskins
but he does going to talk about the
great reset movement covid
and here we have the world economic
forums the great reset website
saying there's an urgent need for global
stakeholders to cooperate in
simultaneously managing the direct
consequences of the covet-19 crisis
to improve the state of the world the
world economic forum is starting the
great reset initiative
we had on uh destiny are you familiar
with destiny
he's a a leftist uh although the
progressive
i guess the the woke left really hates
him because he said i guess he said that
kyle written out was defending himself
and so they went after him but he's
pretty lefty
he said he said isn't uh a crisis like
covet the perfect time
to do reforms to make the world a better
place isn't doesn't that make sense
so so uh i think the issue is
uh put a pin in that now i'll mention i
had alex jones on the show and i asked
him
what if what if they're right that you
know humanity is hurtling towards
non-existence extinction because we're
destroying this planet stripping
resources and just burning ourselves
alive
don't we need to do something isn't it
is that possible and alex actually said
you're right i think about that all the
time yeah maybe but you know this is a
very serious challenge
and then ultimately what it comes down
to hearing this from say destiny or
hearing what alex thought about it
it's a question of your right to impose
what you think is right for the rest of
the world
and here's where the real real problem
comes in if you came to me and told me
tim the world is on fire and it's going
to end soon
i'd be like that's a problem what can we
do to solve it if i trust you
what if you're not right what if you're
just another crazy person like all the
rest of the crazy people who thinks they
know what the world needs
you've got fascists who think they know
they know what the world needs i
certainly don't trust them
you've got communists who think they
know what the world needs i don't trust
them either
so if someone comes to me and says we
must impose authoritarian rule over
all of the people of the world to make
sure we survive i don't have any good
reason to trust what you're saying
i want the world to survive i want to
mitigate these problems i personally
think we got a problem with climate
change and you even mentioned
we've got we got a problem with
resources but who do i trust
who do we empower to put the boot down
over everybody else
so i a doctor once told me i love the
saying
people don't sue outcomes they sue
relationships so here's my relationship
with these elites at this point in time
they just lie about everything so
i'm actually fairly sympathetic to this
line of thinking if they said listen
we're 7.8 billion people normal
trajectory we're going to nine maybe 10
billion that's a fact
that's going to happen by 2050. here's
where we are in the resource story
here's how much oil we think we have
left here's how much fresh water we
think we have left
there's a there's a gap here we have a
problem on our hands but let's pull
through this together so this would have
been like going to the nation
back in 1940 and saying we have to
defeat nazis right
and as long as you're honest about that
people will go okay you know if if
people know what the vision is they will
crawl through mud
literally you ever seen those people do
those mudders right like just crawling
like because they have tough mudder yeah
and it's team based and they want to do
it so people do amazing i have great
faith in people but i think what you're
talking about is that the people who are
pulling the strings up there right now
they don't have that same faith in fact
they
actually don't trust us so that means
we're in a relationship that's not based
on trust and so your question is a good
one which is why should i do anything if
i don't trust you
well well here's an interesting
conundrum i suppose you've got
the what is the ipcc you know a
consensus among scientists climate
change is happening
how do you feel about what's your
thoughts on climate change it's very
complicated
i've put not enough time into it to
really understand what's going on but
i get the basic theory of it and i don't
want to get into the actual politics
that arises around it but i just wanted
to point out
that you've got a large faction of
people who don't believe it's real
if you get someone like al gore coming
out the documentary and doing a
presentation saying you know here's
what's happening
and half the country believes it half
doesn't then i i don't necessarily agree
that if they came out and said here's
our plan people would just agree to do
it i think a lot of people would just
say no you can't tell me what to do
but it's not necessarily around the
climate change this resource story is
more direct more linear so ocean
acidification is something i believe in
completely because it's very simple you
take the partial pressure of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere
and the higher it is the more there is
the more goes in the water the more
acidic it becomes period and i know i've
talked to oyster farmers who can't grow
oysters in both maine and in
in this puget sound because the
ocean's too acidic but the jellyfish
comes in yeah and we
can eat people are eating the jellyfish
now i've never tried it is good
have you looked into iron fertilization
yeah this whole idea that we're going to
geo-engineer our way out of this i think
is
here's complexity theory is the most
important thing i've ever learned
and in complexity theory there's a
couple things like even if we had a
computer and we're modeling
sand being dropped when exactly when and
how much is that pile is going to slump
we don't know we can't predict it
we don't that defies us so when you say
do i believe in climate change it's not
a question of belief what i'll tell you
is it's not just a complex system it's
hundreds of nested complex systems our
ability to predict
that is zero right but we can sort of
look at the larger trends
which i do believe in but anybody who
has certainty about where anything's
going to go or how it's going to play
out
i don't know about that side of things
but ocean acidification is dead simple
tell me how much how much co2 is in the
atmosphere and i'll tell you what's
going to happen
and so i've i've worked for
environmental non-profits and
we like we talk a great deal about the
dead zones that have appeared and say
like the gulf are you familiar with
these
yeah from all the nutrient runoff yeah
yeah so and there's also the other
problem uh
you mentioned fresh water i did a mini a
short segment
on a desalination uh desalination plant
in
i believe it was carlsbad california and
a lot of people are saying oh you look
we the whole world is water we just got
to get the salt out of it we can drink
it what they don't realize is first of
all that creates
a mass movement of the water into other
areas but the brine runoff
from the when they pull the the the
brine
they basically takes hot water and they
pull out a bunch of you know water
molecules which gives them fresh water
they get a really dense salty brine
which then rolls down the bottom of the
of
of the ocean bed killing off all of the
smaller life forms creating this wave
that goes all the way up creating a dead
zone
where now there's nothing alive anymore
so that desalination is not a solution
to this
so that ul ultimately what i'm getting
to is
it seems like we can't just keep doing
what we're doing
can we nope that's the point so then we
just can't well so then so but
where's where's the balance between an
individual's right to choose and live
their lives for themselves and
huma like shaking humanity by the
shoulders and saying like you are
burning things to the ground what do we
do yeah but but the people who are
saying that
things are burning down that they're
lying through their teeth and usually
they are connected to individuals who
are doing the burning
so when we look at the actual pollution
when we look at the actual issues that
the earth is facing
whether with natural resources or not or
or some of the studies that manipulate
the data to to highlight that maybe it
is declining maybe it's not declining
a lot of this is contrived by
organizations that benefit from this
that get more power and control by you
believing some some
of these things and then they extort it
to get power
taxes they they wanted to do a carbon
tax on individuals
cnn again lambasted individuals for
for eating meat and they're saying
because of climate change you're going
to have to eat less meat meanwhile
they're not even talking about the
multinational corporations that are
mostly responsible
for the the carbon emissions that are
going on there and they're shifting the
blame on the individuals
when they're the ones creating the
problem that they magically have a
solution to that we have to go along
with that's crazy i think a really good
question that needs to be answered is
when you look at greta tunberg
she complains about the us and europe
and she ignores china and india
why is it if i'm if look i'm i'm here
with you man i'm ready to
to fight for the environment and all
that good stuff but i got a real i got a
real
problem with the ig when we ignore
a couple a couple very important
questions we ignore china
and india and they're pumping out tons
of carbon and i don't see gratuitor
complaining about that
the u.s is actually working hard to
reduce carbon emissions
find other ways to produce energy not
like it's perfect but then you also see
these these elites
who fly on jumbo jets and have big
houses but more importantly
buy beachfront property yeah like bill
gates bill gates recently bought beat
beachfront property haven't all of them
bought properties
but this is the thing we also have to
understand a lot of china's pollution
was predominantly responsible because of
other countries
sending their garbage to them and they
said that they're going to recycle it
they didn't recycle it
they sent it into the oceans and then
the world found out that cycling and
recycling mainly
uh in part was a large scam on the on
the people i think i figured it out
i think if you're dead you see all these
rich people buy this beachfront property
right
because they really want to live on the
beach barack obama just did it yeah
recently
but but then they're sitting there
thinking like i just invested you know
10 million dollars in this in this condo
right
and it's going to be underwater in 20
years so they go to their body and say
how do we stop my condo from going
underwater i know
let's lock everybody down so that no one
can do anything
because then they know we'll save
resources that means
the elites i'm i'm half joking by the
way well there's
climate change zealots right now that
are coming out in mainstream media
publications and they're writing
editorials how we need to continue these
lockdowns we need to prevent people from
riding cars we need to prevent people
from traveling
to stop climate change after we defeat
the coronavirus
we still have to continue these
practices because they're good for the
environment
meanwhile they point to the
responsibility at the individual
rather than the actual corporates the
culprits who are responsible for it and
it's absolutely sickening
and it's totally disingenuous quote
journalism it's pr propaganda for the
very rich to become richer
they they they they write that the
great reset is a conspiracy theory that
people think the elites are just locking
us down
because of climate change and not really
because of coven i got an article here
from the world economic forum themselves
emissions fell during lockdown let's
keep it that way
yep well there you go i don't think we
must know that they're saying it
so if somebody says they're going to do
something and then it happens it's now a
conspiracy
theory to suggest that that might have
been what happened well that's what the
new york times even wrote they said if
you talk about the
the great reset your conspiracy theorist
it doesn't exist it's not here meanwhile
other
other publications are like celebrating
it and saying that this is going to be a
great enemy
it started out with you you had you had
the world economic forum writing the
great reset here's what we're going to
do
then when the right conservatives and
libertarians started talking about it
the new york times said oh it's a
conspiracy it's not real
then about a week later you started
getting these these mainstream
publications
just defending the great reset saying
far right you know white supremacists
etc are attacking the noble and great
reset
like we we are all working together for
a better world and these far
right white nationalists harambe say
yeah but here's the thing that's that's
the trajectory things go through
you could ask uh every one of those
journalists and say what
exactly does the great reset entail and
what impact is it going to have on your
lives nobody knows
nobody has any idea about this right
except that you don't drive your car i'm
not going to own anything i'm going to
be happy about that i'm going to rent
everything
have no privacy no privacy that's all i
know about it so far
that's you not them i think
there's going to there's going what i
think i see happening right now is
there uh for a long time in the united
states upward mobility was a thing the
american dream
existed for people even people who who
were not from here
could emigrate become american find
their american dream you could be in
poverty in the old country come here
work really really hard and eventually
your kids are living better than you've
ever dreamed and you've got your own
house and you've got to represent that
ponzi scheme to the top well so what's
happening now is
the american dream was upward mobility
you know in some countries there's none
because
it's class based or cast based well
what's happening now is
with the great reset i think what
they're going to do is there's a hundred
ladders that you can climb for that
upward
upper upward mobility 99 of them are
getting the ax
right now and they'll keep one or two
some people will be allowed if they
approve of you and you you help them
and they will get to continue flying
around on jets running the world
doing whatever they want but hey look
emissions are down the world economic
forum says
let's keep it there i don't think that's
good does that does that mean they won't
be flying no it means you won't be
flying exactly
that's that's a great point that you're
making there and when you look at upward
mobility it's virtually almost
coming to a point where it's impossible
in the united states you look at low
skill labor
that's being replaced with immigration
you look at high school labor
with with programming there's a whole
bunch of visa programs that are
outsourced to india and china
that are literally shipping in labor
into the united states so people going
to college right now
getting into debt for the rest of their
life come out and there's there's no job
prospects out there and there's going to
be less and less of them
we were already facing a large economic
turmoil
especially in the retail market before
the coronavirus
now there's going to be a huge reckoning
and a huge restructuring
the great reset it's here it's the
largest transfer of
wealth and they are they're enforcing it
with brute force if your business
if if you don't if you don't transfer
your wealth to amazon to walmart to
target
the police will come after you they'll
shut you down the irs will audit you
and they will make sure any semblance of
self-responsibility any semblance of you
being able to fend for yourself
is eliminated and that's exactly what's
happening right now and it's sickening
so there's one funny thing that's going
on right now is there's a
there's a call to boycott walmart and
it's because
josh hawley republican senator announced
he's going to be objecting to
the electoral vote count supporting
donald trump the walmart
official twitter account tweeted i
wonder if that newsweek article has the
tweet they do check this out
walmart tweeted walmart the actual
twitter account for verified walmart
go ahead get get your two-hour debate
soar loser
walmart had to issue a public apology it
was a team member who forgot to switch
accounts
and conservatives are like no like we're
going to boycott walmart
well progressives seeing the opportunity
were like yeah
conservatives woo you're right let's
boycott walmart
and they're going we actually just want
to boycott walmart because they're a
massive corporation that rips off their
employees and doesn't pay
fair wages and then i'm sitting there
like i don't care what your reason is
for boycotting walmart i think walmart's
trash
i think we got to support mom and pop
shops so if you're mad about them
tweeting at josh hall and you want to
boycott it
i'll take it if you're a progressive it
doesn't like they're paying wages i
agree with you
so how about we help the small
businesses the the little people who
need support right now
and we stop shopping at walmart i'm with
it i mean i mean walmart's taking their
profits from us right now and they're
investing it back into wuhan china of
all places which is absolutely
disturbing
what do you make of all this chris are
you with uh are you going to boycott
where are you my boycott walmart
i have been for years i'm way ahead of
the curve okay so excellent
i haven't been i haven't been i've been
a little lazy on it and uh
i saw a tweet from jen pelman we had on
the show and she said
we should boycott walmart because like
you know they don't pay fair wages or
whatever
this is true i mean walmart pays trash
and then their employees have to get
welfare to make up the difference yeah
it's a subsidy yeah i'm like
why are my taxes going to that that
doesn't make me happy
so yeah maybe walmart should pay better
yeah this is the ponzi scheme that's
going on right now
many people aren't being paid a living
wage and they have to go on government
assistance which of course is paid for
through the tax dollars it's another
subsidy that they're receiving
which is an unfair advantage than anyone
else in the business field this is not a
free market capitalistic society
this is a society by the rich foreign
living wages are money from the federal
reserve that are
not sustainable we got to pay back with
interest it's completely unknown there
are no living wages right now let's say
living buying power or buying value for
the moment but it's not sustainable no
no no no i'm not talking about the
federal reserve i'm saying people need
to have a way to sustain themselves with
proper buying power and the federal
reserve strips that away
that's the problem i agree with you so
what i'm saying is
you got a lot of people who are mad at
walmart because they insulted josh
hawley who was supporting trump
come on board let's let's let's but
listen listen
conservatives all about helping the
small business owner and the people who
are fighting and working for themselves
i agree with you we should be shopping
at the boutique stores but they've all
been shut down
so the government not only is paying
a subsidy wage to the the people who
aren't being
paid enough by walmart we our taxes
cover that
and then the government comes in and
shuts down all the small businesses
forcing us to go to places like walmart
talk about
a lucrative merger between corporation
and state oh there's a word for that
uh oh fascism i thought i thought all
the left was supposed to be fighting all
that but here they are really cheering
it up
the last definition of fascism is ultra
nationalism and traditionalism
and they argue that even though i
believe i believe mussolini said it was
the lucrative merger between corporation
and state for like a singular purpose
it was nationalistic but i think look
when we say fascism we usually just mean
totalitarian dictatorship you know
single party rule and why are we
left and right we got we got to come
together and let's you know you get left
over here and right over here we all
crack beers together and realize
for different reasons we're mad at
walmart can we all agree that walmart is
bad
and it's i'm sorry for singling out wall
actually i'm not sorry for singing like
singling out walmart
other stores too it's target it's these
big box stores
and it's amazon amazon's so easy
whenever we need something it's like i
can just go to amazon boom it's there
and it's prime it's delivered
we got we got to go back to supporting
people
you know the problem we have right now
money is being siphoned away a transfer
of wealth it's not just happening
because of coveted in the lockdowns
everything that the left has pointed out
referencing that walmart
doesn't pay enough so their employees go
on welfare and then our taxes
pay for those people that's another
transfer of our wealth to a massive
corporation
yeah i'm not cool with that or
individuals like jeff bezos so i was
about to say can we please do
amazon too because they had 1.5
billion items that were delivered just
during this holiday season they had a 50
percent increase
since last year's holiday season in the
amount of people that use them and this
is a company working on
the latest and greatest police state
technology quantum computing to break
encryption artificial intelligence
they're working with the cia they're
working with the pentagon
if there ever was a legitimate threat
against your civil liberties against
your freedoms
against your economic future it's it's
it's amazon let's just i got all these
things on amazon the gorilla 2 and the
crystal ball and the plasma ball
yeah yeah i think i got this glass on
amazon
it reminds me this thing too maybe it
reminds me of uh idiocracy
where costco is just a massive
multi-square mile building where like
people get lost into
it it's incredibly convenient when they
can drone deliver things through the
stratosphere when we're going to be able
to drone
ship materials like into the in the
desert
because we're just launching these
drones it's going to be the way we're
supposed to live
i just don't like one guy owning that
you know well i don't want to seize the
production but we
maybe there's a better way to nobody
centralized the ability that's why i'm
all about mixed economy i don't like the
idea of
the in here's what i don't like i don't
like when
the regular working-class person loses
their rights to to figure out what they
need and trade as they want and that's
to get with full-on socialism or
communism
when the regular working-class person
loses choice i'll tell you what i really
really don't like
i don't like jeff bezos extracting value
and destroying mom and pop shops
i don't like big box stores setting up
next to a boutique
shutting them down i don't like
starbucks setting up next to
a a small town mom and pop coffee shop
and then dropping their prices to gut
them out and then once they're gone
cranking the prices back up
that's a problem what's at the root of
all this the job
obviously capitalism i say you know what
the workers of the world you know i'm
kidding
it's the job economy right what do you
think it is it's money
it's just money it's like this old
biblical sort of understanding of mammon
right so mammon comes out and and
confuses people with his shiny baubles
and people do crazy stuff against every
principle they have
we have corporations right now that will
do anything for that bottom line
anything so one of the things i track is
insects birds all the stuff i'm kind of
an outdoor guy right and they're just
plummeting they're in decline
and they're what what birds birds
massively birds aren't real
no i'm kidding somebody who's somebody
was posting in the chat over and over
again i know i don't know what that was
about it didn't take
it was a failed meme it did not launch
but um no there's a there's a subreddit
called birds aren't real and they they
go at it i know they keep trying but the
capital team try it's painful at this
point so let's keep moving
so what kind of birds are you tracking
um all of them all the migratory birds
at this point
they're just yeah they're in huge huge
decline everywhere they've had this
massive barrier
that just happened just this past week
in white sands in new mexico
the place where they were trying to
migrate but they just couldn't make it
they just fell out of the sky sparrows
all kinds of things everything migratory
yep they were falling out of the sky
mm-hmm why getting emaciated they're out
of food so the insects are all gone
yeah so i'm old enough you guys might
not know this but when when we would go
on family trips right get in the old
woody station wagon you know no seat
belts was that kind of an era
every gas stop which was plenty because
the cars got sick for for mileage right
i would have to crawl out and try and
get the bugs off the windshield and they
were just
thick right but not just one type not a
swarm of mayflies
there's grasshoppers and dragonflies and
big things and little things
you don't see that anymore i i now drive
hundreds of miles over the course of the
summer and might get one
bug it's not because my car's
aerodynamic they just aren't there
we got spider crates here and we're
doing that things yeah those things are
nasty
they're a little scary right and we're
doing that because we decided to switch
to a new brand of pesticides called
neonicotinoids and we did this because
it's just a little bit cheaper
right yeah and they get to sell a couple
billion dollars worth but we're taking
out the bottom of the food chain so
the larger story around the same story
as walmart the theme for me is
we have to get back in right
relationship with ourselves with our
workers with our with our biosphere like
if we don't get this relationship thing
right and we keep going
spiraling down this great reset control
everything
i think it ends badly uh regardless i
think people wait wouldn't the great
reset help solve that problem no
it would exacerbate it unfold because
it's the same people
the heads of monsanto the heads of all
these regulatory
groups today joe biden just picked a a
gentleman that's deemed
mr monsanto as the top head of the usda
today well there's change you can
believe in yes exactly
and those are the same individuals
bringing in the great reset so we're
going to have
we're going to have you know mr monsanto
at the head of agriculture
that's going to make everything right
for you i mean i'm sorry it's going to
be naive to believe
any of these individuals because when
you look at their track record when you
look at what monsanto did
not just with roundup but with so many
different instances that i could bring
up here right now it is
absolutely dumbfounding why they are
still allowed to be
an entity that exists it's crazy you
hear about the rat that was trying to
eat a pigeon in new york city
no they're that hungry huh yup they're
all out of cheetos and and dog hot dog
rides well there's also a story today of
squirrels attacking human beings exactly
a squirrel squirrels have been attacking
people in new york biting people
because they're getting desperate and
you know it's it's really interesting
i watch these videos of like you know a
cat and a bunny and they're like laying
together
and because they're well fed exactly i
was reading like why is it that we claim
that dogs and cats hate each other and
in reality like you'll see a video of a
dog and a cat laying there and you know
fat and happy
even for for like a lion you can have a
lion a small little pig or something and
the lion won't leave it alone because
they're well fed
and it's they don't want to waste energy
fighting fighting is dangerous it's
scary
if they get free food from somewhere
else they got no reason to do it now
we're seeing a rat fighting a pigeon
and some dudes swinging at it but now
squirrels are attacking human beings
desperate for food because when they
have no choice
they would rather fight you even though
they know they're gonna die because
they're like i'm gonna die anyway you're
making me think about humans man
that's how humans are too yes yes and so
what happens
when this lockdown carries on longer and
longer and people start smashing their
way
into these businesses because they have
to eat
or drink water it'll be
that's not we need to figure out what we
want to be in a city right now yes
that is a recipe for disaster and what
you were just talking about i mean it's
something that i also observed
this summer driving around in the united
states i was like
why aren't there a lot of bugs in the
windshield like there used to be when i
was a kid when we had road trips
and there's none and it's terrifying
because when you look at the kind of
ecosystem it's being interrupted it's
being interrupted in record levels that
are
going to have a huge impact so when i
talked about those complex systems
before here's how they work you
mentioned jellyfish there's a great
story about this right
in the adriatic sea they had sardine
fisheries for thousands of years
thousands of years and finally they just
overdid it just you know mechanized
trawlers gps you start six inches from
where you left off last tuesday you know
nothing they scraped the ocean clean and
once the ecosystem said oh there aren't
enough fish and the jellyfish could get
in towhold and then they took over
they now have a jellyfish ecosystem and
nobody has a clue how to undo that
well that because it's like the marble
went out of the fishbowl and went over
to the jellyfish bowl and that's where
this is going to have a huge effect on
our food industry and people don't even
realize this
do you know about the mussels in lake
michigan in chicago there's
invasive species the zebra mussels you
mean yeah yeah yeah we had those in the
lake that i went
yeah it starts spreading like crazy
invasive species so so listen though
if all these bugs are gone and we have
these acidification and dead zones
and now they're saying that because
we've locked everything down for a year
that co2 levels have you know dropped
and emissions are going down and stuff
like that
won't that help solve a lot of this
problem won't that help
insects come back and and ocean life
come back up to a point uh
the work i do in the world is about this
we need a new narrative so we live by
stories and we had this story that was
running for thousands of years stop me
if you heard it
be fruitful and multiply right at a time
when that story came out and they're
like this is a kick-ass story you know
we need to use this it's because you
know there were basically a few million
people on the planet
we're at a different part of the story
and i think that's what the great reset
people are are wrestling with i think
they're doing it inelegantly i think
they're doing it
you know a little bit duplicitously but
we need a new story that says how do we
live within our means how do we live
within our ecological budget because
what used to be you could just sort of
overshoot that and who cares and it
always bounces back but now it's not
bouncing back
and that's what people are feeling i
think because we evolved on this planet
through billions of years
that we can feel that on some level and
i think that explains why people are so
anxious right now because we're
we're kind of destroying the place we
live on but i don't think i don't think
we need to be put in check i think
they need to be put in check because
when you look at the ones most
responsible for pollution when you look
at the ones most responsible for
pesticides
they are the ones who are responsible
yeah but that's why i don't trust your
solution you were just mentioned well
like 73 percent of americans are fat
uh either obese or overweight according
to a new report
i'll i'll i'll yes we could all be
better of course i agree with you no but
listen i think the problem is two-fold
you've got massive corporations that are
pumping out carbon emissions and
and and i see this from the left they
say stop demonizing the people
it's the corporations that are
responsible for the majority of
predominantly yes
yeah but it's the people who are buying
and demanding that the
just them when we're talking about
monsanto these are people that leveraged
government at almost every element to
get an unfair advantage to do whatever
the
hell they wanted to yeah and it's not a
free market competition
no one said hey i really want to support
uh gmo seeds now i really want
you know frankenstein to go into the
laboratory and build some
gene splicing between pigs and tomatoes
no one wait one voted for that
incentive is that real um there's a lot
of gene splicing
going yeah i mean i you can check up the
direct references but there is crazy
gene splicing experiments that are
remembering done remember when homer
simpson
spliced tobacco and tomatoes together
yes i remember that
and then for some reason the tobacco
inside the tomato was already dehydrated
like i was like what is up with that
well you know there's there's things
that of course people never
voted for and there's many ways you
could vote you could vote with your
dollar you could vote with your
attention
by watching this podcast you are voting
with your attention
and it's a huge way to incentivize what
you want and i think i agree on that
element that we as human beings need to
realize every decision we make
does have an impact we do ultimately
matter
we are the change that we want to see in
this world and if we're not doing good
we're not prepared we're not responsible
for ourselves no one else will be
i'll put i'll put it simply man look i
am so on board to save this planet we're
talking about ocean acidification
climate change the birds falling from
the sky the bugs are gone i'm getting
scared right
and then i'm like all right obama tell
me what to do and he's like well
i just bought a boat in a big 30 million
dollar mansion on the beach and i'm like
okay
you're clearly taking this seriously
dude what am i supposed to do
remember after an inconvenient truth
comes out right you know and and
scares a lot of people and you get to
the end of it and it's kind of like well
maybe you should
i don't know maybe you should like put
some compact fluorescent light bulbs in
you're going what the well how does this
connect
but so i actually go to the website i'm
like okay what is he up to
mr gore and then you find out he has six
homes with a collective 60 000 square
feet of
of you know not him not him it's not
about him and all that but
you know the reason i'm really excited
to be here is because i think there's
the problem definition is great
but this is where the new story comes in
and there's all these young people in
particular every revolution starts with
young people right
i feel like the great reset is really
just a lot of older people yeah you know
saying
here's how we have to hold on to this
you know keep it all stitched together
but there's young people
farming in ways that are regenerative
i've seen people at scale
like building soil in ways where
everything comes back in natural
abundance so it's not that we're
we can't do this people like oh how if
without monsanto how would we feed the
world the truth is we can
there's models out there but we're not
doing it i think and we should
i think we we got a great glimpse of
this when uh the leftists took over
the the autonomous zone and they had
their larp farm where they were throwing
down cardboard
that worked out if they didn't it didn't
work out but one thing that you were
advocating for
was for individuals to learn how to farm
how to be sustainable to themselves
there's many benefits to this and it's
something that i've been telling people
to do as well and i think it's key and i
think it's crucial and i think we're
reaching a point where
it might be even essential so the great
reskilling i think that's what's
that's that's the great movement that's
coming skills graphic is going to change
everything are you familiar with it
graphene yeah that could they figured
out last year how to print graphene from
carbon dioxide
by depositing it onto copper and
palladium with hydrogen turned in oxygen
so it's going to come to a point where
we're harvesting too much carbon dioxide
and we're competing with the trees
and we're gonna have to build an
industry for the 21st century that
works in tandem with the trees so that
we don't
use too much of it i just bought these
uh graphene composite batteries
they have two and a half full cell phone
chargers like external batteries
they charge in 15 minutes that's crazy
yeah the 20
it's the new steel it's gonna change
everything i mean it already has
um we can also use iron fertilization to
reintroduce iron oxide into the ocean to
grow the plankton
so that it'll it it has some carbon
dioxide
uh sequestrant capability but it's more
for
creating plankton for the fish to regrow
the fish population and the and it might
have
might solve the jellyfish that's all
that's all very promising
ian but where does intersectionality and
diversity come into these programs
they get to go into the space are the
people who are developing these iron
oxide things do they have a board that
is equally male and female with some
non-binary and non-white individuals
yeah because the great reset
incorporates this intersectionality
stuff too for some people from all over
what is that what is that that's that's
that's the other thing look i can
criticize like greta tunberg for saying
like how dare you and then getting on
this you know like really multi-million
dollar trip
on the ocean that like no one could do
in like in their lifetime
and she says all these things and and i
can criticize that
but also i'm just curious what does
intersectionality and like wokeness have
to do with
it with with fixing the planet so
it's a useful tool to push their agenda
it's a useful tool to subjugate people
to see
each other as different to divide and
conquer them so they could easily
conquer us
and have us fighting each other rather
than realizing the actual crap that
we're in it's like they're bored like
when you're focused on something you're
not thinking about if you're a man
you don't that doesn't enter what you're
working on you're doing something that's
that thing you know what i am is not
there when i'm working on that
did you see the viral we've got to give
people something to work on you see the
viral tweet that asks
like it asks all cis people to think ask
themselves these questions
because they'll realize they're actually
trans no no joe
and like i think james lindsey who's
like one of the foremost experts on
wokeness wrote about it like like
they were proposing like a fake study
where you know everyone is trans
but there's like th this is what we're
actually seeing transactive is saying
every child should be put on puberty
blockers
we're seeing trans activists say that uh
you know everyone is trans and things
like that
and uh i mean you know if you are you
know do your thing that's cool uh i'm
just wondering how
the the intersectionality wokeness
non-binary stuff
that's incorporated into all this is
it's like
how why am i how am i supposed to
believe that these people are serious
that saving the planet when they're
talking about stuff that's totally
irrelevant to it and flying around in
private jets
that's my problem i want to believe i
want to believe that
i don't want it i want to get a flow
toilet yeah i'm not going to flow a
shower head and it's like trickling down
you can barely shower and you're like
well i'm doing what i can for the planet
but then they're they're getting like
i tell you these rich people they've got
those showers where they have like five
jets all around them and it's raining
like the whole building it's like a
thousand square feet of just raining on
them and they're like
you know apoptosis that function of
nature that where cells will just kill
themselves
if they're no longer needed that's real
that's scary that's that
that's how mentality apoptosis
let me just say one thing if you live
in the middle of nowhere and you're on a
well i don't think there's a big deal
with taking a long shower right because
it's like it's
just well water it's not going to go
back into the earth or something right
yeah it's like the cities that are
straining and taking up too much fresh
water is that the problem
well this whole idea so they've been
pushing things down like there are
issues
you mentioned this luke right so it's
like if you could just be a little bit
better and buy a smaller car maybe have
a smaller life or just you know shower
for
you know on a low flow for just a couple
minutes all that
that isn't going to do squat when when
you really look at where we are there's
difference
so a problem has a solution and we talk
about a lot of things like their
problems but other things are just
predicaments and a predicament only as
an outcome you got to manage that
right so japan has an aging population
and it's getting smaller
that's a predicament there's no solution
to that that you're going to solve by
passing a new law
but what are they doing with their
banking system they're just printing
more and more and more debt because
they're like our economy has to grow
yeah no the economy should shrink it
should shrink just like their people are
shrinking that's
the economy should be in service of the
people but they have it all backwards so
in this story you're mentioning all
these things like
intersectionality and things like that
they don't even relate to the
predicaments we've been just talking
about
like to me the most important thing is
we should have a national and if not a
global plan that says
what are we going to do when not if but
when all these fossil fuels really begin
to wind down how are we going to feed
everybody what does the future look like
what do our cities look like
where are people going to live what are
they going to do these are big questions
i mean people are being forced out of
cities because of all the chaos
one of the things i was saying is that i
think one of the on the bright side is a
lot of people are going to start to
understand the value of hard work
you got your choice but you can't if you
have no job and you need to eat you got
to figure out how you're going to eat
you move out of the big city go to the
middle of nowhere build your own little
shack and then farm
now what you mentioned with japan is
that also actually happening
in china because of their one child
policy they have an inequity between men
and women
and they're also trying to figure out a
way to of course keep their economic
growth by keeping their population large
and they're having a hard
time because they don't want to open
their borders europe on the other hand
their populations are declining very
rapidly and
some european economic economic
analysts are saying that we need to open
the borders we need to let the third
world in to
help give more people so we have more
economic growth in
our country that's literally what they
were arguing and i think we also have to
see exactly what's happening as the
populations of
of japan decline and the populations of
the western world decline as well
i think those are also things that are
very eye-opening
now i'm i'm in this totally
whack-a-doodle camp of people who
believe that you can't grow forever on a
finite planet
so this whole idea of economic growth
that's marketed to us on all the time we
need growth when you growth it's always
positively phrased we're gonna have more
jobs we're gonna have more growth we're
gonna sell more houses we're gonna more
and more more
any you can work it out it's not hard
math it's like eventually that stops
right so the question is not does it the
question is how is it going to and are
we gonna do it in a controlled way or in
an uncontrolled way i think the great
recess is kind of like a first sort of
clumsy stabit
let's see if we can do this in a
controlled way because the uncontrolled
way is a hard
date with a brick wall that's that's
kind of i i don't want to
i would rather not do that myself but
the question is what do you do about
that and the first thing you have to do
is
people need to be told the truth about
this and the simple truth is you can't
grow forever on a finite planet there's
a limit and we've hit it
there's only we're already at the here's
the thing right hold on hold on
virtual reality that's actually you know
what
that could be pretty cool yeah we're
like we harvested so well uh no no
no sort of matrix here's what i'm saying
greta tunberg
said the idea of infinite economic
growth is insanity and i'm like
i don't know i kind of play a video game
where you you spend money for digital
nothing
and that makes the economy move so you
can have virtual economic growth
if people start getting really heavy
into virtual reality and virtual spaces
you can own things that don't exist in
the real world you can buy
and they're they're video games where
there's property that's worth a ton of
money where there's spaceships or the
ton of money
armor sets weapons the virtual world i
think will allow for us to have economic
growth
doesn't have a negative your computer
can be mining crypto
in the background like right now you can
set your computer to be mining manero so
you could do that with your body too
but that's but that's that's still
physical world stuff i mean like
what if if i want to buy something from
you you produce it now we've
extracted a resource from the planet
what if we're in a virtual world
and you gain the sword of a thousand
suns or whatever and i'm like oh i
really want that
so i buy it with currency and no impact
on the real world
where would your body would your body be
like in stasis no you'd be in your house
and you'd say
playstation vr then there's then you've
got to eat you got to sleep you got to
drink water not saying
we we go like we stop being alive i'm
saying that instead of growing
our economy in terms of building a new
building we build a virtual building
we have meetings in vr where we go into
certain spaces it would diminish the
the weight of the real world but you'd
still need to eat
tim pool would still need food and
resources but he wouldn't need a whole
six houses on the career oh yes you're
going to use many things because you'd
be satisfied with your digital things
yes you so we can start building new
worlds
and the other thing too is it's not just
one world you could have a spaceship in
one virtual space you could have a home
in one virtual space
and we could do a ton of things yeah but
we're about to colonize mars
like we're really about to say well so
an interesting an interesting idea too
you're mentioning like you know infinite
growth is impossible
uh it's it's like we're yeast you know
what i mean it consumes the sugars and
farts itself to death until there's
nothing left
and then we eat the bread uh there was a
there was a video i watched explaining
the problem of
you know constant reproduction and they
said imagine there's a jar with a
bacteria in it
every you know minute the bacteria
splits so a minute goes by and others
too
another minute goes by now there's four
then you know eight et cetera et cetera
once they get to the point where they
fill half the jar they say whoa we got a
problem
if we don't find a new jar in one minute
we'll run out of space so they find a
new john and say we're going to colonize
this new jar
a minute goes by now the full not now
the full bottle is full and say don't
worry
the next time we split we'll go to the
next bottle they split again now both
bottles are full and it's great now we
need two bottles
now we need eight bottles 16 et cetera
et cetera so colonizing mars isn't a
long-term solution
it's uh it's it's
mitigates a lot of the problems but i do
think you know when i hear stuff like
you can't have infinite economic growth
i think digital spaces and virtual
worlds are going to be a big
solution to this because if you look at
games like world of warcraft
it used to be that you could have a job
where you played the game mining you
know digital gold
and then selling it to people for real
currency so you have jobs that
just didn't really produce much of
anything it was a virtual thing that
anyone could like
people who work for blizzard the game
company could have just typed some
buttons and boot and the currency
appears kind of like what they're doing
now right the point is
we can have it so that people are
excited about the things they own
not in the real world things that don't
have any physical weight to them that
don't have an impact
and how many people do you think would
be satisfied with that world
uh i think all of them
so it's it's really just an issue of
culture acceptance
dopamine triggers and things like that
i'm sure the great reset people know
this but like you mentioned there are a
lot of really old people that
they kind of don't get it they're very
clumsy about it when they say that in
2030 you'll own nothing and you'll be
happy i'm like well yeah ignorance is
bliss
if you take away the idea of freedom
from people they won't miss it because
they'll never have known it
existed i think that's horrifying but if
people
get enjoyment out of playing video games
where they can have
rank skill be a warrior with with
special weapons that are unique to them
that they earned they'll be happy by it
that could be a possible dystopian
future
and also why but but also why big
companies like facebook and google have
been investing an exorbitant
amount of money specifically in the vr
space i think that's also interesting
but
you lay out a possibility that could go
either way but you're not that far off
as a possibility to what could actually
be happening here because i could see it
we already have individuals that are
glued to their video games
to a point where where they are
literally wearing diapers
why is that dystopian no no the diaper
thing okay it's over there
it depends who controls it if google and
facebook control it which they're
getting market share
of the development of the of the
implementation when they're getting
first to market
then i think there's there's reasons to
concern when someone like facebook
controls it all uh but if it's done
independently
decentralized in a way that is uh
you know done in a fair competitive way
then i think
it is possible but when you look at the
the space and how it's controlled right
now
i think it's more headed towards what is
hoping yeah this one is microsoft
uh patent w0202060606 cryptocurrency
system using body activity data
where microsoft wants to put something
inside of you and track your body's
what you're looking at and it'll see if
you're looking at a commercial it'll
register that that's the commercial
you're watching and it'll pay you crypto
just for experiencing it
so you could do that right that's
microsoft that's freaky but let me ask
yep
what if in the future you people live
humble lives
they have small houses where they you
know they work they sustain they're
self-sustaining and then they have
you know this virtual reality system
where they can go into all these crazy
worlds
i love it all right is it dystopian no i
do it every day
i was on the computer for 12 hours today
i i stay on the computer i'm in the
virtual realm as
much as i can be sometimes i wish i
could have five days in one day
yeah you would take normal yeah but i'm
not going to be first in line so so i
also imagine
what if what i'll wait until like 12
years i'll wait listen
it's what if neural net created the
ability for you to actually plug into an
entirely different world
just totally fictional make sure that
world's safe no no but
it's like it's it's your world it's a
game world where
you're not in the real world anymore and
it's a video game and you can have your
your you can be satisfied by the open
world you know what i mean you can go to
you
you can be in star trek you can travel
through space but you're in internal
universes
you know something i've seen a lot
because i have a lot of people coming to
work on my little farm
and certain people of the younger guys
they don't know how to use their hands
anymore and i'm sure every generation
says these kids these days right but no
there's something really missing from
the screen generation
and it's problem solving spatial
abilities all this so i hear what you're
saying tim there's this chance that you
know we could
satisfy the endless human wanting with
this in virtual
in a virtual way which does attack some
of the resource issuing but
where i'm going with this is i think
it's time to admit that
you know we need to be in relationship
again with each other
in an important way and with ourselves
and with our tactical
abilities because there's a there's a
way we learn
that requires us to actually manipulate
and use things so i think a lot of
people think they're just gonna you know
i have the
worst conversation i have is people like
well chris if things ever get that bad
i'll just go out and hunt i'm like you
should come with me sometime because you
won't survive here's what i mean here's
what i imagine
i imagine harder than you think here's
what i imagine you say that you have
like this young guy in your farm
and he's like you know after a few
minutes he goes my hands
why do they hurt and you go because
you've never used them
my friend said hanging from tree
branches improves your i think he said
it was improves your balance
he'll like spend a time every day
hanging from a tree branch
it's a monkey a monkey thing yeah
apparently it's really good for the
human body
well luke just got his weird you know
whatever power power lifting
power cage we're still waiting for the
weights and uh one weight came just one
yeah
just one i can't really do much with
that but yeah today did some running
today
you know it feels good i love it people
need to work out more and be
incentivized to work out more and take
care of themselves because sadly a lot
of people are in a really bad place
where
they're incentivizing some of the worst
behaviors because the corporations are
just giving
giving it to them on a silver platter i
think the laziness is incentive
that's why i like augmented reality as
opposed to virtual reality
um because you can actually go outside
and be in the dirt and be farming and
see like bonus points every time you
like weed a garden you get like credits
that that's a good i like that but you
do your gut microbiome
by by actually farming and doing that
you do get
you do then you just say physical
medical benefits by doing that
let's take pokemon go and make it so
that in order to catch the pokemon
you got to plant a tree yes yeah yeah
sort of like pokemon go meet sim city
meets farm
you're like you're you're imagining this
number i'm kidding but imagine real life
so so we have you know pokemon go where
they've actually used like google maps
data to create gyms and stuff
what if they actually mapped out areas
that were in need of cleaning
you know there's garbage and then part
of the game was like you earned points
you could pay crypto literally a utility
but it's not even it's not about paying
someone so that they can have money it's
about
incentivizing the game that could be
given what does someone earn by catching
a pikachu in pokemon go exactly
they get to accomplish something that
makes them feel you could interact with
your friends that are also playing the
game like if
you see them weeding the garden and you
help them you know do it together you
could get bonus points working together
yeah yeah reddit karma what's it worth
nothing but people want it oh
they want it bad points all right we got
to read super chats everybody let's do
super chats if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to the show
and uh
share if you really do like it sharing
is the most important thing you can do
because it's the only real way we're
going to grow is if people like it and
they recommend it their friends
and if you're on listening on itunes or
spotify leave us a good review because
that also seriously bumps us up and then
more people see it so it's
greatly appreciated but now we're going
to read what you guys have to say
and uh we'll start let's see friendly
neighborhood
sawyer says hey tim consider doing a
segment with former co-workers and other
witnesses to recount their version of
the ufo sighting you mentioned
in a recent recently uh segment
but that was i mean that was 2006.
it's uh been a long time since then so i
don't know where
those people are dunk uh it was a ufo
story
duncan massive says thoughts on lauren
southern's new film i haven't seen it
have you guys seen it
what's it called crossfire i haven't
seen it nope versey says bring adam on
for the end of the year
you start with him finish with him uh
we'll see how things go
oh yeah new year's eve tomorrow man
we're gonna figure out what we're doing
luke luke wants to do like a crazy i
said let's go to the shooting range
where we could use the flamethrower and
have a
crazy bash and then nice bring it back
to the old days where we do the live
stream we do the show through the cell
phone and a place where you can use a
flamethrower you're not going to get
cell phones
maybe we'll see we can we can go early
in the day we're going to do some
research tomorrow
and uh i think that'll be really cool
you know interesting have a freedom send
off to 2020.
you can get you hey you can get a
satellite for your rv that gets
streamable in it yeah
yeah i mean you're not going to get it
by tomorrow but you know maybe we'll see
all right let's see astronaut kitty says
tim does your beanie get stinky
yes but uh i actually have a ton of them
and they get washed
but i have a whole bunch people don't
realize this you got three
from uh for christmas luke got me a
cupcake beanie cupcake beanie and a
light up a beanie with led lights inside
i got one and a a
yeah yeah i i that was my christmas gift
for we have a shirt coming soon that
says i am a gorilla i'm excited for that
it's just because people keep i want to
get one of those shirts
yeah i want to wear it on the show trump
it's like tim going
for those all right let's see selty says
ca is proving the definition of insanity
masks and lock-ons didn't work newsome
says
more lockdowns yeah well you know things
are going to get crazier and crazier
what this one says uh roadrunner 76b
says i bet kevin james's channel has
better audio than than us
yeah probably he's rich and he's got
great production it'd be cool to have a
tech guru come in here and just do a
once-over on the show
like a lighting thing especially we did
it's just that the issue is
some people talk like this you know so
um and thanks for having me
and you're like we gotta crank their
volume up and then some people talk like
this
and you're like whoa we gotta turn the
volume down and you just gotta change
volume and stuff so then
then it gets out of sync and we're
constantly trying to fix it and
sometimes people talk really quiet but
then later in the show start ramping up
and then getting louder and louder and
louder
and then you can see it in like the audi
like the file when we're at it when
we're editing it's like you can see the
audio slowly getting bigger and then it
was like
yeah it's funny it's like all right
that's where the yelling is
jg miz says saw chris i was like i need
to watch this live
was researching coveted in november uh
got uh got serious
on january 13th i basically scared
myself so dropped into mental in april
i found cm i have watched him every day
i love both you guys
cool nice thanks ben walker says
spamming the chat because i think this
is important
medcram dr sehult vitamin d i'm not a
rich man but i think that's important
vitamin d toxicity is incredibly rare
obese people need more vitamin d
melanin makes vitamin d from sun harder
to absorb
is that true true wow interesting i've
heard that different people from
different cultures need
more and less amounts of vitamin d like
someone from africa
where they're used to getting a lot of
sunlight there's their body
tends to be uh they require more is that
what it is more vitamin d
because well they need more sun because
they make less vitamin d per unit of
skin per sunlight and so yeah and blacks
have been affected by covalent a lot
more than other demographics out there
which is also important to point out
yep jmack says the crazy thing about
covid is just how varied it is with its
symptoms and people will use the
exceptions and extremes when it's
beneficial to the narrative they want to
push
my wife had it and suffered mild
symptoms me and the kids were 100 fine
and then you have you know some people
who get like you know blisters or
whatever
or now the new york times is saying some
people get psychotic
toes we heard when we look at the media
we see a wide range of symptoms a wide
range of just information and it's
hard to know what's what's true
sometimes but we literally went from
blue toes to
psychosis yeah like that's a lot yeah
it does attack a lot of things yep it
does dakota johnson says respect and
appreciate everyone's perspective
we the people need the ability to have a
congressional recall upon desire and
better control over where and how our
taxes are spent
both by the state and federally i agree
with that is there like a way to file a
redress of grievances
for i did a prototype for an app where
we could repurpose our taxes
collectively it's on my la on my youtube
channel it's the last video i did
yesterday
very cool that would be cool if we could
vote on on uh
you know tax appropriation people could
all vote where do you want to go so if
you want to go to transgender studies in
pakistan that's fine
let the votes sort of count that and see
what happens with it but
i wouldn't have portioned it up this way
i think everybody who voted for that
563 page bill should be summarily fired
yes yeah yeah you don't need a bill you
should be yeah perjured or something
well well hold on somebody slipped in
that the pentagon has to reveal
everything they know about ufos and 180
days
yep so they didn't read it it's in there
hey there
okay that's a bonus but but here's the
best part it wasn't even in the bill
it was the the provision for revealing
ufo stuff
was attached to another bill
that was attached to the to the omnibus
so like in the omnibus it's like here's
the
the intelligence authorization act and
then they said
you can see what we're funding somewhere
else so even if you read it you wouldn't
oh that's insidious
i know but but but yes but
this time it's going to get us ufos so
that one's okay
you know what i mean that's the one
thing i'm actually okay with like well
we did get that right
is it worth the trillions of dollars
being printed so we can finally no i'll
tell you what's going to happen in a
couple of months they're going to come
out and say here's everything i know
about ufos
and it's going to be like there are
things in the sky we don't know what
they are and they're going to be like we
need to print another trillion dollars
what if what is that you don't know
nothing you think how many trillions do
you guys think they're going to print in
2021
oh man 17 am i overshooting it's a big
number
30 trillion if we if we look at the
number the graph right now
they did how much trillion did they did
they do this year it was like
uh that they created i think it was what
four
three or three or four trillion yeah
they went for this year but but that was
just
base money and then the banking system
amplified that about right right by
doing what it does
yeah yeah yeah oh so it's actually
substantially more than that and that's
just the u.s federal reserve
you can't look at anyone in isolation
you have to look at all of them so i
look at
the bank of england the ecb yeah bank of
china you put them all in one spot bank
of japan
it's a massive number this year yeah
it's just gonna exponentially increase
until you know ten dollars gets you uh
you know just like a pint of milk
instead of a gallon and
that's gonna be 50 bucks a gallon and
you're going to be struggling to you
know get people
should i buy bitcoin that's what they'll
be thinking when it's 50 bucks again oh
we got one for you ian
justin bookman says i love it after many
episodes trying to argue about the banks
ian gets his moment
and tim can't do anything about it
loving the conversation chris is on the
show
thanks to luke bringing chris on the
show loving the conversation while i
wait to get loaded by the way
luke recommended a pistol you guys are
awesome and ian gorilla chest thump i'm
a gorilla that's what i'm
talking about i can't wait till we get
these shirts because i'm a gorilla it's
like a gorilla like
a gorilla yeah all right let's see we
got here
dbz dragon says this reminds me of the
premise of the movie elysium
yeah although you know what i loved
about the movie the people in the space
space station spoke french and the
people on earth spoke spanish like what
is that supposed to be like
the the snooty elite speaks spanish and
the poor people i'm studying early speak
french and the
poor people speak spanish like what's
that all about it's like france just
like super rich or something their their
their debt to gdp is nuts
it's like 230. they're still going like
crazy
turkeyface says thank you chris for your
early and continual covet coverage
you've helped a lot of people with your
info keep it the great work and don't
let big tech silence you
thanks i won't ethan till they do
johansen says
solution to climate change is having us
farmers plant more plants
and letting plants change the soil
instead of plowing it keep co2 in the
ground too
feed our cows more grass too i like
putting a roof over my cows heads too
though
you know i went to a bunch of farms in
california during the drought
and there was like one farm i went to
and the cows were doing their thing but
there was no
there was no gate like it was just open
and so i was talking to the farmer and i
was like
there's no like enclosure and he was
like okay
and i was like but like the cows will
leave and he goes yeah and i was like
so don't the cows leave he goes yeah
sometimes i was like wait
hold on you have cows your dairy cows
they just leave and he goes uh-huh and
then what they come back
and i was like really you're not worried
he's like no i got food i was like oh
but i was told all the time that like
cows hated it it's miserable it's awful
and he was like
no i like it here i was like oh okay i
guess they're really bad factory farms
though if you drive down like uh i think
like uh was it route 88
california no through texas when you're
like driving south you can see a
bunch of really nasty mud pits and like
but
he's right about the cows so i got cows
this year decided we're going to get
cows that's how you learn about cows how
you learn about anything you get them so
we get these cows
two of them went in the freezer but we
have these two belted galloways we had
this big snowstorm and all proud because
i just built a pole barn for them i used
my own sawmill trees from the whole
thing it was like this whole like you
know
little house in the prairie but with a
modern sawmill right so a great moment
so the first morning of that snowstorm i
stumped down to the to the barn because
i'm like i'm going to watch them
enjoying this enclosure i built for them
and i get down there and they're not in
it they're out in the middle of the
field just
lying down with 17 inches of snow over
both of them they look dead so i stump
out there and they're both happy as can
be just lying there so that was
that was the cow choice they they choose
what they want to do
right our survivor civil civilization
should have chris on
yeah yeah yeah i just thought it was
crazy that like he the guy basically
said the cows will leave sometimes
and i'm like you know he's like nah they
come back like they want they want to
eat you know
so they'll go do their thing they don't
want to go and they're happy i was like
wow that's crazy i didn't know that
yeah it's kind of cool because i hear i
hear a lot of a lot of horror stories
you know let's see
dressiel says tim i work at walmart pay
is a lot better
i make 18 an hour even the door hosts
produce and auto associates make base 50
an hour it's gotten a lot better and
would be good to point that out well
then uh
you know i i can respect that that's
probably true i take your word for it
i've i've certainly heard that people
have said walmart's tried to improve
their image on that
and it's also true that you go to
walmart during like peak hours and they
have like 20 registers but only two are
open
probably because they're paying people
better but they got a lot of self
self-checkouts now so that's probably
another reason why people are getting
paid more which probably means a lot of
people lost their jobs
yeah well there you go my google thing
just came on
they thought that someone was talking to
it that's so freaky it happens on my
phone all the time on the show
and then i see it recording everything
i'm saying and the words are popping up
i'm like okay that's not that's not okay
that's why you turn that feature off yes
you can turn it off all right see ethan
johansen says first of all you'd have to
eat 50 000 bushels of corn in order for
roundup to hurt you
however us farmers hate monsanto too
cover crops
uh cover crops will help get away from
them look up gabe brown and ray
uh archuleta for more info on
regenerative regenerative agriculture
cool gabe brown is one of the people i'm
thinking of at scale this guy operates
three thousand acres
thousand head of cows cattle or
something and and he's just he's
building soil he's doing a beautiful job
no inputs
no chemicals it's amazing cover crops
it's just
it's beautiful with no pesticide
herbicide fungicide nope he's not doing
that so uh unlicks ghost says check your
account 600
should be in there tonight also maricopa
is having its rally be at washington dc
january 4th
through the 6th you know we saw this
story that dallas apparently like
grounded a bunch of flights because
there was like a coveted breakout or
something
i wonder if there's gonna be some
unfortunate
transportation errors and mishaps just
before the six cause
i feel like people are gonna show up
when you know if if you've got people
who aren't super political
breaking in the doors of a supermarket
because they want to shop what do you
think trump supporters are going to be
doing
you like people i'm seeing people
posting they're going to fly across the
country to drive across the country
we'll see how it plays out i suppose
emperor guy cerric says tim foyle had
time
trump could not be trusted again on
board with the great reset so they did
everything possible to make sure he's
out of the way
these religious true believers will do
anything to quote save the world
perhaps perhaps let's see okay i read
that one
cindy smith says uh gavin newsom
companies plump
jack cos got more than three million
dollars of ppp funds
one winery got a million dollars with 14
employees 12
820 abc news story then goes to fancy
dinner parties yeah ca is angry
and that's the problem man i want to
believe that we're all fighting the good
fight
in this together they're not in it with
us there's this really funny comic
where it's it's a four panel comic and
there's like a woman and she's like you
know i'm
at my infinity pool in my private condo
social distance saying that one guy's
like i'm on my yacht
and then there's a woman like sitting in
her like filth
in like a crummy apartment with a can of
beans on the ground she's like they're
just like me
yeah just like you brad's organic and
clean energy says i'm an hvac technician
and organic farmer
sustainable farming is one of the most
vital building blocks of a peaceful
future i can see
hungry rats and squirrels losing in new
york city i emailed you guys about
collaboration
dude there's there's gangs of rats
running through the streets of new york
because there's no food anymore they're
becoming aggressive and angry could you
imagine like you get bit by a rat
okay the doctor get that rabies shot you
know or a squirrel jumps on you and
tries eating you like just desperate to
just
that's okay you'll just be sent home
with covid yeah yeah it's like i got bit
by a squirrel so you're saying covet
no squirrel the squirrels actually still
latch to my back
yeah covet it is all right go home and
then
call animal control yep
joe uh joe rob says could you use neural
link with your pets
hmm yeah they used them on a plane yes
yeah
they were testing them but so far it's
like neural link actually transports you
to a virtual reality world you know
right now right now yeah yeah getting
that right part would be very you know
that's where things are crazy oh my god
jesus saves but doesn't trust banks says
tim i don't know if you saw my super
chat yesterday i wanted to know your
thoughts on objectivism
after replaying bioshock i want to know
if you think it can be implemented and
work in today's world as a solution
i don't know enough about objectivism
other than objectivists think
libertarians stole their ideas
what is objectivism like ein rand what
is that
uh they believe that all of the
wealthiest people should
get in a private plane and fly to west
virginia to create their i'm kidding
i don't know it's like uh i don't know
enough about it and i don't want to you
know get it wrong
but general i think it aligns similarly
in some ways with narco capitalism and
libertarianism but i do think there are
distinctions are you familiar
with i don't know how much because i
talked to an objectivist who said
libertarian stole our ideas and i'm like
okay
like i don't know what does that mean
does it mean you're libertarian no we
were the originals
okay oh here objectivism is phil phil's
office system developed by
ein rand well libertarian ideas are
great
libertarian candidates are horrible and
they make everything let's see
if they can i understand associated with
them they could just dress better that
would be a great start
didn't some dude like take his pants off
i was there in person as that was
happening
i was filming there i just like
flabbergasted
i don't know he just i mean it's the
libertarian
convention and they were like arguing
debating whether you can sell heroin to
kids
yes like conservatives
and very other adult topics that we
can't get into on this family-friendly
show but it was
and then the pants came off yes yeah at
least it was entertaining but
there was a literal gap was it like in
the room there was like was it like an
argument no of like you're not a real
libertarian you're not oh yeah and he
wears his pants off no they were given
some time to speak
the guy came on stage and he just
started stripping and
everyone was really i mean some people
laughed but a lot of people were
disappointed but he proved you were all
fake libertarians
because if you really believe in freedom
you couldn't stop them from getting
naked
so what's objectivism um ayn rand
described it as the concept of man as a
heroic being with his own happiness as
the moral purpose of his life
with productive achievement as his
noblest activity and reason as his only
absolute
yeah interesting this is very vague it's
kind of like a
periscope i think the idea like some
people believe
well i'll put it this way i don't trust
a centralized group of
you know davos group type people to know
how to solve the problems of the world
i think a decentralized system would
probably solve it much quicker and more
efficiently
and that tends to be the case it's it's
like a billion minds
focusing on a problem are going to come
up with a variety of solutions and a
better solution than one mind trying to
figure it out
now you can argue that one supercomputer
can be equal to a thousand regular
computers
but one person is just one brain
compared to a billion brains
now i'm not sure that humans agree
enough to get the problem done before we
get great filter out of existence so
it's a serious conundrum the problem is
who do you trust to put
to put the boot down and force people to
take action i don't trust these people
because
gavin newsom gets a bunch of money and
then goes in parties
barack obama's buying beachfront
property that i don't i don't believe
these people i think they're lying to us
i think we all think they're lying to us
all right let's see we got here sam
meehan says tim you should look up a
film 2047
virtual revolution it explores a lot of
what you've talked about today
cool sounds like a black mirror episode
too but like imagine if you had the
ability like imagine that the matrix was
real right
but you weren't a prisoner enslaved in
the matrix you were free to leave it's
just the world was boring because nobody
was really doing anything and it was
like
not a whole lot to do but in the virtual
world you have 50 50 different realities
where you've got various characters you
can go to the one world where you can
fly and you know throw fireballs in one
world where you're the president
you'd have a lot of fun have you guys
ever smoked salvia divinorum
because i will tell you the matrix is
real we are in it right now
i once worked for a venue where a dude
smoked salvia and then just dropped to
the floor and just started staring at
the wall that's what happens
they ran in and like they couldn't bring
them back out of it i smoked it
and i saw the grid and it was twisting
and i i felt like i was twisting but i
just saw this i could see
the major dmt what one of my crazy
favorite videos ever is gardening on
salvia
i have not seen that what happened a guy
he comes out and he starts to explain
he's got a trowel he's got a plant
he's got some fertilizer he starts
explaining he says but first i'm gonna
take a hit
smokes up some salvia and he gets about
halfway through a shovel full
and then he starts crawling around then
he just lays down for a while and
uh that's how the whole video goes it's
good that's the
they call it the diviner sage that's
what salvia salvia means sage divinorum
is the diviners
that's what the natives called it right
on the device all right let's read a
couple more of these here super chats
again if you haven't already smash that
like button
all right let's see what do you got here
mafu says tim can you make some
react to super chat videos i think you
can make some more moolah love your
buddy and i'll be looking for you
wednesday
um yeah perhaps we have the proprietary
website coming soon and we're gonna have
vlog content and members-only content
we're gonna have bonus segments
so you know we typically try to keep the
show it's supposed to be eight to ten
but we always go over like we're going
over now
but you know i'll do my best but then we
wanna do like you know we're going to
wrap up the show and then we'll record
another 10 minutes
the uncensored all the things that we
can't say that we're going to say it'll
be on
on the website which is coming soon
which is going to be really really great
and then
uh of course yeah we'll we'll have more
interaction with those who have
questions and
the idea is that we want to have like a
commenting system kind of like a discord
not but not discord where
you can as a member comment on videos
and ask questions and we'll we'll all be
you know
uh engaging and you know i think that's
a that's the best path to creating
something sustainable it allows us to
make sure that if there are things we
think we need to talk about names we
need to say and and
you know stories that need to be you
know brought up we'll always have a
place to do it
there there hasn't really been anything
i think that uh
there are a few stories we can't do
because youtube will take the video down
the stream the live stream down and it's
almost like well what's the point
just to like claim we tried if it gets
taken down then we're not saying
anything to anybody
that's why we need this website up soon
and that's what we're going to do so
it's going to be really great and it's
uh and we're going to do a bunch more
stuff too a lot of a lot of stuff in the
work
i will say too uh in reference to
scanner as well a lot of people
were asking questions about like what
what's going on with scanner you know
rocco and emily are doing their thing
and i just want to point out i hope
everybody realizes
covid like really just like disrupted
everything
i mean we were i was trying to buy buy a
building set up an office and hire
people and do all this stuff
in 2019 and then once we got into winter
and we were trying to figure out you
know how we were going to set up
the new studio and a lot it's a lot of
stuff happened we were moving
once covid came in this is everything
was just was frozen
and it made everything really really
difficult so i'll just say that you know
um
but uh yeah we're definitely going to be
expanding doing a lot of great work so
uh definitely
stick around thanks for hanging out let
me just uh read a couple more of these
super chats
silently in atlanta says lydia might
like this guest mike rowe
ask mike about the farm episodes and the
poo poo pot maker
fun alien perspective is end of
battlestar galactica i love that show
uh mike rowe i'd love to have you on the
show mike's amazing i i interviewed him
before i might be able to find some kind
of contact information
and right now he's on this big campaign
that's called
safety third and he talks about how
we're we as a society are failing
because we have too much of an emphasis
on being safe and being always a hundred
percent okay
and in reality you have to let go of
that if you want to progress
and what he's doing right now his
campaign is something truly
something to look forward to and uh to
promote i think i'm i'm pretty sure i
broke my left wrist
uh skating maybe like a week and a half
ago and
then i was skating a few days ago and uh
i tried to do i was just i was just
warming up i was doing a switch flip
but this sometimes happens where my my
front foot landed on the on the nose of
the board
and my back foot hit the ground which
caused the board to spring straight up
like a hammer and whack my
thumb so hard it was throbbing it was
brutal pain now there's like blood all
over the nail
look you got to pay your dues man that's
what we that's what we call it you know
i'll be skating with with like adam and
adam will
will like fall down and and you know
bust his ass and we left
you want you got to pay your dues i took
the leaf blower and i and i got on the
skateboard and i saw what it could do
you know we have we have flamethrowers
for a reason we got to play with them
all right we've got to figure out how
things go boom what i'm saying is
you want to skate you're going to get
hurt when i see little kids on the half
pipe and they're scared to drop in
i'm like you're gonna fall and they go
what i'm like you're gonna fall
accept it as a fact and then get on with
it the longer you stay up there scared
and don't do anything
you're never gonna do it the first time
i tried to drop in on a quarter pipe
i fell down and i got hurt and i laughed
and i ran back up and then i did it
you have to accept that you're gonna get
hurt you're gonna get scraped you're
gonna get bruises
and sometimes the accidents are really
really bad and not everybody makes it
sometimes you're driving down the road
trying to be all safe boom hit by a car
did you see
sometimes you're staying home because
you're too scared to go anywhere you
slept in your bathroom boom hit your
head in the sink now you're dead
tom segura you know tom segura one of
rogan's best friends
he he was playing basketball man and
fell down and shattered his arm his bone
is completely broken apart his
his knee got shattered like i'm nervous
about snowboarding after that i'm i want
to just
think for the rest of my life you stay
in front of me
we went outside when it snowed here and
i put on the snowboard
and front flipped not on purpose
and then i just started i i hurt i had
like scrapes all up my arm
and i was like i did a front flip today
i was like oh really not on purpose but
you know it was fun
i was i was snowboarding down and i'm
not a snowboarder i can snowboard
but i just leaned forward and it was all
deep fresh powder and i got caught and
just
front flipped and it was awesome and i i
landed but then i fell backwards because
i didn't really land
and then my wrist has already kind of
broken because i fell on it and i was
like ah
my wrist ah it's funny and i'm just
gonna keep getting injured
i've i've messed my ankles up so bad my
legs are covered in scars
pay your dues i can walk them i think
there's just people that like
rough housing and people that don't of
course like some kids would always want
to play basketball maybe throwing elbows
into each other's faces and like haha
and i'm like god it hurts so bad i don't
want to
i don't want to elbow someone and i
don't want to get out but skateboarding
always hurts
because falling is a part of
skateboarding you just keep doing it you
get better at it you get really
consistent but
you know you'll fall you whack your shin
and then you go oh man getting you like
you'll do a tray flip and the board
your shin it just happens sometimes it
happens i mean you get good enough
eventually it stops happening but
you're always trying to do better so
maybe you'll learn how to do a 360 flip
that's where the board spins 360 and
flips and you can land it every time
well now you're trying to do a 360 flip
crook and you still whack your shin
because you're always trying something
new
anyway with that being said you got to
push your edges though you have to do it
yeah if you ain't flying you ain't
trying
exactly you got to give it a go there's
always risks we're not immortals
well if there's if there's no danger
it's not actually an adventure
yep yeah it's just there has to be real
danger if you don't make any mistakes
you won't have any stories to share
but what i was what i could do as a kid
was amazing so
so most of what i was doing as a kid was
a felony now right right
we were mixing things up and putting
them in pipes and having fun right we
did stuff like that right you can't do
that no
you can't do that no but you know unless
you're making youtube i'll tell you
i'll tell you what else when i was like
seven years old
i'd leave the house my mom would be like
come back when the lights come on
that's it that's it yep i'm gone and i'd
like go around and travel just like all
throughout the neighborhood
and like try and see like how far could
i go before i got scared and went back
home i was like a little kid
now it's like it's a little if a
seven-year-old there was one story where
a kid was playing in front of the house
and someone called the cops
and the cops were like why is this kid
alone and the mom was like he's in front
of the house
walked home from school had cps called
on him yeah and you know most kids don't
walk past the five block radius in a big
city
these kids are going to be emotionally
and developmentally
disabled but safe they already are yeah
let's be honest
safety first safety first 53rd yeah
no it's it's real i think it's a tragedy
i really do i think that
how do you ever find your edges i mean
particularly you know for me as a
my pack of boys that i ran with we were
pushing our edges all the time and
everything was unsafe that we did
we just go to each other to do
increasingly sometimes you just gotta go
to venezuela
or somalia yeah or epstein's island
whatever it may be
crazy it's the craziest thing because
like
uh you know i was talking to my dad he's
a firefighter
and i said something the effect of like
you know it's kind of you know it's
brave of firefighters
they rush into these buildings they know
they could die and he goes no they don't
if a firefighter thinks they're going to
die they won't go in the building they
don't do that they think they're going
to be safe because they know how to be
safe
and when they get word the building's
coming down or the fire's out of control
they think they're going to die they'll
leave and i'm like that's a good point
so when i uh luke and i have both been
to some of the craziest places in the
world
and i always get asked this question
like you know after coming back from
some crazy place like wow why aren't you
scared like you could you could die or
whatever i'm like dude if i thought i
was gonna die i wouldn't go there
i'm going there because i know how to
take care of myself thailand
was the craziest why is that because
they were actively shooting at each
other
i got i stood in one of these these
vehicles where they would parade around
in this big truck a bunch of people
would stand in the back and they'd all
wave and cheer
and there were vehicles one of these one
of these trucks someone pulled up with a
motorcycle and threw a grenade
right into it boom bloodstains all over
the bottom of it
and so i actually rode in that after
that happened and the blood stains are
on the ground
and i'm wearing like this crappy fake
armor because it was the best you could
get because it's kind of you can't like
armor is
considered a weapon of war whatever
blackjack well so what they were doing
was they're taking sheets of x-ray film
and stacking them and then putting them
in sheets to use as plates
because they considered armor to be uh
like a war
material or something in thailand so
here i am in this truck there's blood
stained at my feet and it was a discount
vehicle that's where they bought it they
were like because of the blood nobody
could
so they bought it and we're driving
through the scene i'm like this is crazy
yeah and they were just like just keep
in mind if you see the motorcycles try
and pull up that's when you like jump
out
get down the shooting starts and i'm
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
i watch them pull down like just topple
stat scaffolding and i'm like
dude if i thought i was going to be put
at risk by going there
i wouldn't go there what's the point you
can't you can't do your job
there's a reason i hired 10 mercenaries
to follow me around in somalia
you know otherwise you don't go alone by
yourself without guys with ak-47s it's
just that's just the truth
i mean but sometimes going in stealth is
is safer too not in somalia if you're
my complexion yeah yeah all right
everybody yes we've sufficiently
explained risk to you but uh
thanks for hanging out you can follow me
on twitter instagram and parlor at tim
cast check out my other channels
youtube.comtymcast and
youtube.comcastnews
we are live monday through friday at 8pm
we'll be back tomorrow of course but
smash that like button hit that
notification bell
share the show with your friends if you
really like it because that's really the
only way the show grows
i don't buy google ads maybe i could you
know just like the podcasting appears or
something we'll look into it but word of
mouth really is the number one way
to help support the channel but anyway
thanks for hanging out chris you want to
mention your channel or your social
media
sure peakprosperity.com is the main
website and i'm at chrismartinson on
twitter
and you can check me out at
chrismartinson.com spelled out like a
word dot com
on youtube right on luke i hear that you
have stuff
well the shirt that i'm wearing right
now that says all my favorite channels
are demonetized
or deleted also get on teesprings.com
forward slash stores forward slash we
are change because my main youtube
channel is we are change and it is
demonetized
booted thank you for all you amazing
human beings that are keeping me alive
by purchasing t-shirts like the one i'm
wearing today thank you guys
yeah i got demonetized right away all i
want for christmas
for you guys to remonetize these guys
speaking of remonetize my youtube
channel was also demonetized
because it wasn't very active i was part
of the original partner program
uh but i'm almost at 10 000 subscribers
and i have been making videos
so come subscribe to my youtube channel
ian crossland
along with twitter which is right and
mines and of course you can follow
that's our pitch lids you can you can
follow me if you want to i'm on twitter
and liz is pushing all the buttons
thanks for hanging out everybody
if you're watching again if you're
listening on itunes or spotify or
whatever give us a good review because
you know the way that works is if you
haven't already actually go go to itunes
subscribe to the show tim cast irl
and spotify because that's actually how
the rankings work it's like how many
people come in to check the show and
follow and subscribe
and it really really really does help so
greatly appreciate everybody
we will see you all tomorrow live at 8
pm
adios for now
you